113.
113. Chaos Radio 113 ist hier ein wunderschön genannt. Ihr habt Fritz eingeschaltet und immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Da gibt es hier die Sendung mit und von und durch den Chaos Computer Club und das ist das Chaos Radio. Das Thema in Sendung 113 heute Web 2.0. Warte, ich hab, glücklicherweise hab ich auch Zahnseife dabei, falls ich falsche Worte sage. TV 2.0, da hat aber jetzt Urali keinen...
Vielleicht zweite deutsche Fernsehen.
Ja, aber die merken das erst in 30 Jahren.
Wir wollen uns heute Abend unterhalten über das Fernsehen, wie es ist, was da gerade so am Markt steht.
Ich wollte gerade noch sagen, wer hier so dabei ist. Also das ist einer, der Frank, der da gerade spricht, ist der Frank. Dann ist noch der Markus da, den könnt ihr auch lesen, Netzpolitik Org, schreibt er, und der hat auch noch seine Frauen mitgebracht. Ich stelle vor, Frau 1 JPEG, Frau 2 JPEG, Frau 3 JPEG ist ein Fitz, den ich schon immer beim Radio machen wollte. Der ist aus den 90ern.
Aber wir sind ja auch von unseren Hörern schon aufgefordert worden, dass wir die besten PayTV-Pornosender hier vorstellen und die Hacker ohne Frauen.
Ich fände es ja gut, wenn irgendwer mal diese PayTV-Pornosender hacken und ins Netz streamen könnte, damit ich auch was davon habe. Das ist Hardi Hard, ne?
Hardi Hard, genau, mit dem Spiegel-TV-Intro.
Bekannt auf dem Jast Köln heißt auch Hardi Hard. Und ich hatte über Jahre hinweg völlig ignoriert, dass es auch hier den Hard-Sequencer gibt, der Hardi Hard heißt. Und alle dachten immer, ich wär mit Hardi Hard befreundet. Ja, mein Kumpel Hardi Hard. Hardi Hard, ja. Muss du wichtig sein. Bin ich auch, aber aus anderen Gründen Chaosradio 113 TV 2.0, die Zukunft des Fernsehens ist unser Thema heute Abend. Das wird ein bisschen technisch, das wird aber auch ein bisschen, wie nennt man das?
Ja, ein bisschen visionär. Also wir wollen einfach mal darüber reden, also zum einen, was passiert gerade technisch. Es tut sich, also eigentlich ist es gerade ein Erdrutsch, der passiert. Wir haben jetzt irgendwie, seit es die Bundesrepublik gibt, haben wir eigentlich so die heile Fernsehwelt gehabt.
Naja, das ZDF, RTL.
Nee, RTL haben wir ja noch gar nicht. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Also das haben wir ja alles noch.
Ach du redest jetzt vor über den Anfang der Bundesrepublik.
Genau, da gab es ja die Idee, wir haben jetzt einen öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk. Das ist eine Idee von den Alliierten. Die haben gesagt, wir brauchen was, um die Bevölkerung hier in diesen ganzen Sachen zu befrieden und einen demokratischen Rundfunk, unabhängig vom Staat, nach der Erfahrung im Nazi-Deutschland, was ja auch wirklich eine gute Idee ist. Propaganda. Und dann haben wir mal geschaut, genau, was macht die BBC? Die haben ein gutes Modell und das wollen wir jetzt in Deutschland auch machen. Und ja, darauf sind die Öffentlich-Rechlichen entstanden, wie wir sie haben.
Gibt es eigentlich so eine richtig gute Begründung dafür, dass das damals föderal auch organisiert wurde? Also, dass auf einmal sämtliche Bundesländer eigene Sender gekriegt haben? Weil eigentlich ist das ja Quatsch.
Das weiß ich gar nicht, wie die Idee gekommen ist. Also vielleicht schon auch durch die verschiedenen Sektoren.
Na gut, das wären dann drei gewesen.
Aber vielleicht ging es insgesamt mit dieser ganzen Bund-Länder-Konstruktion in Deutschland. Irgendjemand wird daran verdient haben.
Aber vielleicht kann es das sogar jemand erklären.
Dann brauchen wir es nicht nachlesen.
Genau.
Ja, dann kamen irgendwann die 80er Jahre und dann kamen irgendwann die Privatsender. Dann gab es Sat.1 und RTL.
Vorher kam noch das ZDF in den 60ern. Das hat damals die CDU-Regierung sich gewünscht. Als Gegenpol zur ARD, weil die Meinung war, dass die komplette ARD mit Ausnahme des bayerischen Rundfunks und kommunistischer Rotfunk sei. Da haben sich die Schwarzen damals gedacht, da muss ein Gegenpol gesetzt werden. Die treten uns nicht so sehr auf die Füße. Was sie dann ja auch tatsächlich nicht so sehr getan haben. Das ZDF ist ja tendenziell eher ein bisschen rechtser von der Mitte.
Also es ist jetzt so...
Weiter rechts als die ARD. Außer bayerischer Rundfunk.
Genau. Dann gab es die große technische Errungenschaft des Kabelfernsehens. Die war eine ganz große Neuerung. Das war ungefähr zeitgleich mit der Privatisierung oder mit dem Einführung des privaten Fernsehens. Da gab es in den ersten Feldversuchen, das war so 84, 85 so in dem Dreh rum.
Helmut Kohl und sein Freund Leo Kirch waren das damals.
Genau, weil man wollte den Leuten ein bisschen mehr bieten. Besseres Bild, mehr Programme waren damals so die Werbesprüche. Ja, das war schon technisch eine Neuerung. Das hat dann die Deutsche Bundespost damals gemacht. Noch ein kompletter Staatsbetrieb. Die ist privatisiert worden, ist in die Telekom geworden. Und irgendwann gab es den Wunsch, diese Kabelnetze loszuwerden. Das war klar, das ist keine Monopolgeschichte mehr, keine staatliche Sache mehr, sondern die wurden privatisiert. Und die Kabelnetze in Deutschland, die haben nochmal ganz eigenartige Sachen, eine ganz interessante oder schwierige Konstruktion, da werde ich später noch ein bisschen was zu sagen, wo die Feinheiten sind. Und mit den Kabelnetzen ging es eigentlich ein bisschen weiter. Es gab also mehr Programme, die Programmvielfalt wurde ein bisschen ausgeweitet. Es gab also mehr als drei Programme, die man sonst so hatte.
Wir hatten hier vier. Eine Zusatzantenne, womit du dann Südwest 3 noch gucken konntest damals. Das war bevor der SWF und der SDR fusioniert haben zum SWR. Und Kai, Kais Eltern damals hatten noch eine Zusatzantenne Richtung Holland und da haben wir dann auch noch zwei holländische Sender immer gucken können. Und da gab es nämlich die Formel 1 immer wesentlich früher als hier in Deutschland. Anymotion haben wir damals die Videos von.
Ja, denn ist eigentlich 15 Jahre erst mal nichts passiert.
Doch. Artes ist 1992 gegründet worden.
Könntest du ins Mikrofon sprechen? Okay, danke.
Also Artes ist 1992 durch einen Staatsvertrag zwischen dem französischen Staat und deutschen Staaten oder deutschen Bundesländern gegründet worden. Und Artes, ja, ist...
Aber im Prinzip ja auch öffentlich-rechtlich.
Ja, öffentlich-rechtlich, aber sollte man halt nicht vergessen, weil es geht halt da nochmal Richtung europäische Kooperation.
Ja, und vor allem geht es ja Richtung Anspruch.
Ja, vor allem.
Das Fernsehen ist ausnahmsweise... Das kannst du gucken, zwei Stunden, und das sind ja nicht das Gefühl, blöder zu sein als vorher. Das kann kein anderer Sender, sonst habe ich manchmal das Gefühl... Na gut, Phoenix, wenn sie nicht gerade irgendwelche Debatten oder Krönungen...
Das ist großartig, ganz großes Kino teilweise. Bundestagsdebatten, super.
Die Pressekonferenzen von Westerwelle und so.
Pfff, ey bitte, ey, es ist...
Klar, das ist Hardcore.
Westerwelle, wer will den denn sehen? Ich hab noch nicht wissen, war ich so im Klassentreffen? Also letztes Wochenende, da ist auch einer aus meinem Abi-Jahrgang, der kandidierte für die FDP vor Ort. Und der hat sich so über Westerwelle das Maul zerrissen. Ich glaube, den können die noch nicht mal in der eigenen Partei leiden. Aber Phoenix ist kein schönes Fernsehen, finde ich.
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Aber es sind ja so Abspieldingen eben.
Ja, und die sind ja auch hauptsächlich, ihr Auftrag ist ja auch ein bisschen so, dieses aus der Politik zu berichten und so was. Und das ist ja auch okay. Also letztendlich, ich meine, zumindest heute im Zeitalter der Digitalisierung, Multiplex-Programme, das heißt also mehrere 5, 6, 7, 8 Programme auf der gleichen Bandbreite, auf der gleichen Frequenz, im gleichen, ja, also quasi acht digitale Kanäle ersetzen ja jetzt einen analogen Kanal. Und wir haben jetzt eigentlich, haben wir die Kapazität für so eine Sachen.
Das heißt, DVBt gar nicht am Ende ist, also wenn acht Kanäle, drei ersetzt.
Ja, DVBt ist noch ein bisschen ein Spezialfall. Das liegt ja daran, dass die Fernsehfrequenzen für DVBt sehr schwierig sind von den Bereichen her, weil sie oben und unten begrenzt sind. Da sind dann andere Dienste, da sind dann irgendwie die Amateur-Funker und irgendwie Militär und weiß-nicht-was und Handy-Netz und sowas. Man kann da nicht so beliebig sich ausdehnen. Das ist ein bisschen das Problem, was wir jetzt auch mit den neuen Fernsehdiensten haben für DVBh, DMB, also für das, was nachher auch... Digital Multimedia Broadcast. Was ist das denn? Das ist eine... Kommen wir später noch ein bisschen zu. Das sind mobile Dienste. Was bringt die Zukunft? Und wir wollen natürlich mit euch drüber sprechen. Wie ist das eigentlich mit eurem Medienkonsum? Und wie glaubt ihr, dass es in den nächsten paar Jahren sich entwickeln wird?
Sprechen, wenn ihr mit uns sprechen wollt, dann seid ihr eingeladen, das zu tun, am Telefon unter 0331 70 97 110. Das ist nämlich die nummerale Fritz-Hotline.
Genau. Oder Mail an chaosradio.ccc.de Haben wir jetzt einen Vorleserautomaten?
So wie die Navigationssysteme. Chaosradio 113, Fernsehen, der Zukunft ist also Fernsehen 2.0, ist unser Thema heute Abend. Das nächste, was kommt im Fernsehen oder mit Fernsehen, sind diese großen, flachen Fernseher, die keiner haben will.
Groß und flach, möglichst. Das Skurrile dabei ist ja, dass die Leute gucken jetzt normales Fernsehen. Also das normal aufgelöste Fernsehen, wie wir es kennen, ist ja im Format 4 zu 3 und dieses 16 zu 9 Format, das hat man ja gemacht, um dem Kinoformat näherzukommen, weil es für das Auge einfach natürlicher ist, ein breites Bild zu haben, als jetzt so ein fast quadratisches Bild.
Aber das ist auch Quatsch, ich meine, mein Fernseher ist so, wir haben ja für eine Bildschirmdiagonale 50 Zentimeter, da ist das doch egal, ob das 4 zu 3 oder 16 zu 9, also ich ärgere mich immer, dass die Tatorte neuerdings in 16 zu 9 kommen.
Naja, und das Lustige ist dabei, dass die Leute, die haben jetzt ja diese 16 zu 9 Fernseher zu Hause und die wollen natürlich nicht links und rechts so einen schwarzen Balken haben, weil die haben jetzt so einen blöden großen Fernseher gekauft und die wollen den natürlich irgendwie vollhabenden Bildschirm. So, was machen sie, die skalieren, also das heißt, die verzerren das Bild auf 16 zu 9 und damit wird es ja alles irgendwie ganz breit und wundern sich, warum die Leute plötzlich alle so fett sind im Fernsehen. Vielleicht gibt es ja ein neues Schönheitsideal irgendwie in den nächsten Jahren.
Ja, weil wir wünschen, es wird für die ganzen Tokyo Hotel Fans, dass auch dicke Mädchen dann irgendwann mal gemocht werden.
Wobei ich glaube schon, dass längerfristig dieses Fernseher, also dieser klassische Fernseher, wie wir ihn jetzt haben, 64 Zentimeter viereckig, schönes Sofa danach ausgerichtet, das wird es so glaube ich nicht mehr geben, sondern ich glaube, wir werden in Zukunft eher diese Heimkinoinstallation haben, also wahrscheinlich mit Beamer oder so einem großen Flachbildschirm.
Das ist irgendwie zu teuer, was zahlst du für einen vernünftigen Beamer?
Also nicht mehr als für einen richtig vernünftigen natürlich nicht, aber du kriegst schon für 700, 800 Euro einen Beamer.
Ja, um den Fernseher 200 Euro gekostet.
Ja gut, aber da gehen jetzt gerade die Verrückten in die Kaufhäuser und kaufen sich für 3000 Euro irgendwelche Flachbildschirme.
Echt?
Also zumindestens werden sie angeboten und wenn ich nachfrage wenigstens ein bisschen da wäre, glaube ich, würden sie die auch nicht anbieten. Ich kann es ein bisschen schlecht einschätzen, aber ich glaube, es werden schon Leute kaufen und auch gerade um einfach DVDs, also wirklich dieses bewusste DVD oder Film gucken, sei es möglicherweise auch per On-Demand, aus dem Netz, woher auch immer, dieses bewusste Videogucken zu Hause. Das wird schon sein. Das werden die Kinos, denke ich, merken. Und wir werden auf der anderen Seite haben...
Die Kinos merken das ja schon.
Die Hauptkuppiere sind Verbrecher.
Von ständig irgendwelchen Insolvenzen oder sonst irgendwie. Also das wäre wirklich schon extrem.
Aber ich glaube, es führt einfach, dass dieser Trend ist, man wird sich zu Hause dieses Video gucken, als Event mehr Abend.
Wollen wir es hoffen, dann stinkt es wenigstens nicht mehr im Kino wie in einer Frittenbude von diesen ganzen Nachos.
Das wäre auch ganz schlecht.
Dann würde ich da auch wieder hingehen.
Und auf der anderen Seite glaube ich, dass wir diesen normalen Fernsehkonsum, oder in Anführungszeichen normalen Fernsehkonsum, wie wir vielleicht bisher haben, werden wir glaube ich schon über mobile Geräte haben. Das heißt, da lachen jetzt alle drüber. Sagen sie das Briefmarkenfernsehen oder so was wie das heißt. Oder Streichhörtschachtelfernsehen, wo man dann auf dem Handy so ein kleines Winzbild haben. Aber das wird alles ein bisschen größer werden, aber so, dass es gerade noch mobil ist.
Für viele Sachen reicht das ja auch, oder?
Eben, also Tagesschau brauchst du ja gar kein Bild. Das kannst du ja auch vorlesen lassen, das ist egal.
Das machen sie ja am Brunnenfestgang. Das gibt es auf 88.8 bei den Kollegen. Geben die noch die Tagesschau aus ins Radio. Das finde ich immer sehr lustig.
Das bietet sich ja auch an. Das sind ja auch gesprochene Nachrichten in dem Sinne. Für so die kleine Unterhaltung, irgendwelche Musikclips und so Sachen, reicht das vollkommen aus.
Soap kannst du wunderbar auf so einem kleinen Bildschirm...
Und wer glaubt, dass das alles Quatsch ist, der fährt mal nach Asien, in Hongkong, in der U-Bahn, da sind die ganzen Jugendlichen, die haben alle ihre Playstation-Portable dabei und gucken irgendwelche Manga-Videos oder so. Das ist offenweg von der Schule nach Hause. Da sitzt jeder mit so einem Gerät da und guckt. Da ist es einfach präsent.
Aber da ist wahrscheinlich dann auch wieder wie üblich in Asien, da kostet das nicht noch mal extra, oder? Und hier wird es dann wahrscheinlich wieder ein Schweinegeld kosten und keiner wird es haben wollen. Das ist so mein Verdacht. Das sind die Anbieter, die versuchen, da ja immer eine riesige Markt rauszumachen und begreifen nicht, dass die Leute einfach keine Kohle mehr haben.
Das ist richtig. Aber diese ganzen Finanzierungsgeschichten, da werden wir auch nochmal drüber sprechen heute. Mich würde auch interessieren, ob ihr da draußen auch so denkt, seht ihr das auch so oder glaubt ihr einfach da dran, dass dieser klassische Fernseher, wie wir ihn jetzt haben, eine Zukunft hat? Also wird einfach die jetzige Generation, also sprich unsere Eltern, sage ich mal, wenn die sich nochmal umstellen, wie ist es mit unserem Alter? So um die 30 rum, plus minus 10 Jahre. Wie sieht es da aus? Werden wir unseren Medienkonsum nochmal verändern? Und mit den jüngeren habt ihr euch vielleicht sogar schon damit abgefunden, dass es also ist es für euch normal, dass ihr auf dem PC Fernsehen guckt. Das heißt also aus dem Internet, klick, Video runterladen und da gucken. Tagesschau.de, Livestreaming.
0331 70 97 1 1 0 ist die Nummer der Fritzotline. Die Frage an euch, wie glaubt ihr, dass das Fernsehen der Zukunft aussieht? Würde es überhaupt ein Fernsehen geben, so wie wir das kennen bisher? Also schön hinsetzen aufs Sofartüte, Chips fett werden und dabei dann irgendwelche belanglosen Sachen über die Mattscheibe viel man sehen? Oder wird sich die Mediennutzung ganz ändern, vor allen Dingen die Nutzung bewegter Bilder? Es gibt ja so zwei Fraktionen, die eine Fraktion, was ich ganz interessant finde auch. Man hört sehr wenig Leute, die sagen, so mittel wird das alles werden. Entweder die einen, die sagen, das ist alles Fernsehen, drei Jahren Fernsehen, tot, alles, das ist weg. Quatsch, braucht eh kein Mensch. Ist natürlich völliger Blödsinn. Ist genauso realistisch, wie Leute, die glauben, dass in der Stadt alles umsonst sein müsste. Und dann die anderen, die sagen, Blödsinn, Internet. Geh mir doch damit weg. Das erkenne ich auch sehr viel, in meinem Alter, in meinem Bekannten- und Freundeskreis. Wieso, wenn ich Fernsehen will, stehe ich in Fernsehen ein. Also ist eigentlich ganz spannend. Wie sieht es bei euch aus? 0331 70 97 110. Was macht ihr jetzt, wenn ihr Fernsehen wollt? Und was glaubt ihr, macht ihr in 5 oder in 10 Jahren, wenn ihr Fernsehen wollt? Und was wollt ihr überhaupt sehen?
Lolleck und Bolleck. Stan und Olli. Tom und Jerry. Blasen und Nieren-Tee. Hase und Wolf. Cocktail und Gamble. Coute und Erhaltung.
Fritz präsentiert Phil und Scharkie.
Live im Mehringhoftheater. Phil, das ist der lange. Und Scharki, das ist sein kongenialer Partner und Handpuppenhai.
Ihr merkt schon, ihr merkt schon.
Spaß garantiert. Phil und Scharki live im Mehringhoftheater.
Bei der Versorgung der Überlebenden im Erdbebengebiet auf Java gibt es offenbar Fortschritte, das berichtete Malteser Hilfsdienst. Medizinische Unterstützung gelangen nun auch in entlegenere Gebiete. Die Bundesregierung hat unterdessen ihre Soforthilfe für die Erdbebenopfer auf eine Million Euro verdoppelt. Der Auftrag des BND-Untersuchungsausschusses soll erweitert werden. Das Gremium müsse sich jetzt auch mit der Bespitzelung von Journalisten befassen, sagte FDP-Chef Westerwelle. Darin seien sich die drei Oppositionsfraktionen im Bundestag einig. Bislang untersucht der Ausschuss die Arbeit der Geheimdienste im Zusammenhang mit dem Irak-Krieg. Für die rund 450.000 Mitarbeiter der Zeitarbeitsfirmen sollen ab 1. Juli Mindestlöhne gelten. Darauf haben sich der Deutsche Gewerkschaftsbund und die Zeitarbeitsverbände geeinigt. Vorgesehen ist zunächst der Mindestlohn von 7 Euro in Westdeutschland und 6, 10 Euro in Ostdeutschland. Der Strafvollzug für Jugendliche muss neu geregelt werden. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht erklärte die aktuelle Praxis für Gesetzes widrig, weil es kein spezielles Gesetz für diesen Bereich gäbe. Bislang können Jugendliche in der Haft ähnlich behandelt werden wie Erwachsene. Abends ist es wolkig in Berlin und Brandenburg. Teils gibt es kräftigen Regen, vereinzelt auch Gewitter. In Berlin soll es überwiegend trocken bleiben. In der Nacht dann die Temperaturen sinken auf 4 bis 8 Grad. Morgen Anfang Sonne, dann wieder sehr viele Wolken. Vor allem am Nachmittag gibt es örtlich kräftige Schauer oder Gewitter. Die Temperaturen, naja, bescheiden. 10 bis 14 Grad. Auf der A12 wieder freie Fahrt. Die Vollspörung ist aufgehoben und auch ansonsten haben wir keine aktuellen Meldungen mehr. Wir wünschen eine gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank Matthias Kerkov, 2 Minuten nach Elbelf.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5, dann Fritz in Frankfurt oder.
Chaos Radio 113. Die Zukunft des Fernsehens. Unser Thema heute Abend. Die Revolution wird nicht von der Nerv aus verabschiedet werden. Jill Scott-Heron war das, H-E-R-O-N schreibt man das. Das hat der Markus auch gerade gefragt. Warum eigentlich, Markus? Chaosradio 113, hört ihr? Die Zukunft des Fernsehens ist das Thema heute Abend in der Sendung. Denn Fernsehen wird gerade revolutioniert, sagt zumindest der Frank. Ich hab davon noch gar nicht so viel gemerkt, dass das revolutioniert wird. Ich sehe immer nur, sagen wir mal so, würde ich nicht beim öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk arbeiten und wäre ich nicht verpflichtet, meinen Fernseher angemeldet zu haben, hätte ich den nicht angemeldet, weil ich keinen Fernseher besäße, weil ich zunehmend meine, dass das überflüssig wird. Also das Fernsehen hat mir nichts mehr zu bieten. Und das ist das große Problem. Außer vielleicht Arte, was dann wiederum das ganze Geld wert ist. Dafür wäre ich sogar bereit, 17 Euro oder wie viel das ist.
Wobei es ist auch eine Revolution von oben, nicht von unten. Also nicht, dass wir uns da falsch verstehen.
Also das heißt, das Fernsehen macht jetzt was Neues und ich hab's zu fressen?
Die Leute, die mit dem Fernsehen Geld machen, die machen jetzt was anderes. Also es hat jetzt einfach in den letzten Jahren jede Menge technische Neuerungen gegeben. Es hat sich politisch ein bisschen was verändert. Vor allem aber, wo jetzt die Kabelnetze privatisiert sind, da ist nochmal ein Schub gekommen. Aber ich glaub, das meiste hat das Internet ausgemacht. Das heißt, im Internet ist jetzt Druck gemacht worden. Es gibt neue Wege. Man kann über schnelle DSL-Anschlüsse Videos runterladen.
Ja, aber kaum legal, ne? Also das ist ja das Problem.
Ja, es geht schon auch legal. Und ich denke, das ist nur eine Frage der Zeit. Also Menschen sind ein paar kleine technische Probleme, so ein ganzes Rechte-Management. Und die Leute wollen eigentlich auch nicht auf dem PC Fernsehen gucken, sondern die wollen auf dem Fernseher gucken. Und es gibt noch nicht so viele Geräte, die das auch möglich machen. Also einfach so dieses Bequeme vom Fernseher aus mit der Fernbedienung. Es gibt so eine sehr legendäre Zeichnung, wo interaktives Fernsehen, wie es sich damals die Bundespost noch vorgestellt hat, schon wie die Telekom, wo es also diesen Kaufenknopf auf der Fernbedienung gab. Den berühmt berüchtigten.
Es gab einen Kaufenknopf. Ja, und da stand auch richtig Kaufen drauf. Schön, vielleicht hat davon mal jemand ein Bild und mag das mal irgendwo hin bloggen.
Also es gibt davon ein gescanntes, so eine Präsentationsfolie, die hatte Andi glaube ich irgendwo. Die ist wirklich legendär. Also das war sozusagen einfach das, was man sich damals so vorgestellt hat.
Die Fragezeichen-Taste im Videotext war doch auch so interaktiv.
Ich mein, dann kam ja irgendwann neuen Live von Co. in die Shopping-Kanäle.
Das war ja auch richtig...
Dann fand man mal das innovative Medium Telefon mit dem innovativen...
Wenn du jetzt noch ins Mikrofon sprechen würdest, dann würden mich auch die meisten verstehen.
Eben soll ich noch angucken, wenn wir sprechen.
Eben nicht, aber eben hast du das Mikrofon noch in eine ganz andere Richtung gehalten und dann hab ich gesagt, dann dreh das doch mal so rum, damit du wenigstens ein bisschen reinsprichst, wenn du ihn anguckst.
Das Interessante ist ja...
Das ist aber glaube ich auch das einzige Fernsehen, was aus dem Stand Geld verdient hat, diese Shopping und Mitmachen.
Ja, sagt was über unsere Gesellschaft aus, ne?
Ja, da sagen noch ganz andere Sachen was drüber aus. Ich zum Beispiel sagte oft drüber was aus. Da gibt's ja hinterher wieder Beschwerden von Intendanten. Der Intendantin.
Ne, wir hatten so in den... Vor knapp zehn Jahren fing es an, da kam der Begriff auf der Medienkonvergenz. Und damals war auch so ein bisschen diese Internetblase. Ganz viele haben so was gemacht irgendwie mit den Firmen, die saßen in dem Bereich.
Da gab's doch eine Firma, die hieß auch so ähnlich.
Konvergenz.
Mittlerweile haben wir im Prinzip... Mit dem Internet haben wir jetzt sozusagen die gelebte Medienkonvergenz. Ist zwar nicht so, wie sich die Firmen und die Firmenfirmen denken, sondern im Prinzip ist es ja auch eine Medienkonvergenz, wenn ich mir in der Tauschbörse die Fernsehserie aus Amerika runterlade und dann auf meinem PC gucke.
Sie haben sich gewünscht, darüber die Kontrolle behalten zu können und haben vergessen, dass es digital ist.
Richtig, oder wenn ich mein PC über die Grafikkarte an den Fernseher anschließe, dann gucke ich es ja sogar auf dem Fernsehen. Aber der Weg, die Distruktion, also der Weg, wieder zu mir zu kommen, war das Medium Internet. Und das ist eine gelebte Konvergenz.
Was ist eigentlich geworden, das fühl mir eben noch ein, als es um Fernsehen auf dem Handy ging, was ist geworden aus diesen wahnsinnig high-techigen Brillen?
Weißt du, diese Brillen?
Diese Eyeglass... Weiß ich nicht, die gab's von Panasonic oder so, hast dann so eine Brille aufgehabt und hast dann da Fernsehen drin geguckt. Das war auch so wie ein Tier.
Total super, aber du kannst dich damit echt nicht in die U-Bahn setzen. Also ich mein, das Problem ist, der haut jemand einfach in die Fresse oder klaut dir ein Rucksack und du kriegst es nicht mal mit. Also das ist wahrscheinlich so ein unangenehmer Nebeneffekt davon.
Kann man das nicht irgendwie vielleicht in eine normale Brille einspiegeln? Das müsste doch auch gehen, so Head-up-Display mäßig.
Ja, wär schon toll. Also ich mein...
Fänd ich cool.
Ja, ich auch.
Wir sind ja auch Brillenträger, mein lieber Markus. Die Frage ging an euch. Unter 0331 70 97 110 haben wir euch gefragt, wie ihr euch das Fernsehen der Zukunft vorstellt. Sowohl technisch als auch inhaltlich. Schauen wir nicht in den Chat? Hab ich gerade eine Frage gekriegt. Ich geh da mal ins Telefon. Wir schauen nicht in den Chat.
Aber wir lesen Mails.
Wer sind wir denn? Christian? Wie sieht die Zukunft des Fernsehens aus? Deine?
Also ich hab mir so gedacht, ich bin jetzt nicht so der Experte, was Internet und Fernsehen angeht. Ich benutze zwar Fernsehen und Internet auch, aber...
Auf welche Weise denn? Guckst du Fernsehen? Wie guckst du Fernsehen? Guckst du gezielt Sendungen? Oder lässt du es einfach im Hintergrund plätschern? Und wenn mal was Interessantes ist, guckst du hin?
Nee, so was gar nicht. Sowas hab ich mal gemacht, aber ich hab dann auch gemerkt, dass man dann einfach die Zeit dafür auch gar nicht mehr hat. Und ich guck mir entweder, also was ich ganz gerne gucke, ist auch Arte, wie du schon gesagt hast, oder Phoenix oder sowas. Das ist auch manchmal ganz interessant. Oder wenn halt ein guter Film kommt, guck ich mir den auch an.
Und du guckst es denn, setzt du dich denn bewusst zu dem Termin vor den Fernseher? Oder ist es eher so, dass du dann mal schaust, was läuft gerade, und du bleibst dann bei Arte hängen?
Je nachdem, wenn ich zu Hause sitze und gerade nichts zu tun habe, dann setz ich mich davor, guck was kommt, wenn nichts kommt, mach ich's wieder aus. Wenn was kommt, was mich interessiert, dann lass ich's an. Und wenn wirklich irgendwas kommt, was mich speziell interessiert, dann mach ich natürlich auch da zu dem Fernseher an. Oder nehme halt auch was auf.
Du nimmst was auf, hast du einen klassischen alten Videorekorder?
Nein, wir haben einen Festplatten-Videorekorder, der auf DVDs und sowas brennt.
Direkt von dem, was auf der Festplatte ist, kannst du dann auf die DVD brennen? Oder musst du das in Echtzeit überspielen?
Ich glaube, ich kann das brennen. Ich hab's noch nicht so ausprobiert, weil ich's mir meistens auf die Festplatte speicher und dann gleich wieder runterlösche.
Das ist das meiste, was man wirklich nur einmal guckt.
Zumal die Festplatte auch unheimliche Speicherplätze hat, also ich glaube, so viel kann man gar nicht aufnehmen.
Könntest du dir auch vorstellen, Sachen direkt aus dem Internet oder quasi sozusagen on-demand zu gucken? Wer hat das für dich ein Modell?
Ich hab mir das so gedacht, dass die TV-Sender sich mit diesen Internetanbieter so ein bisschen verknüpfen. Und dass im Prinzip diese Fernsehsender dieses Programm nicht mehr so richtig vorschreiben. Also dass 20.05. das anfängt, beispielsweise. Sondern dass es eher so sein wird, dass der Fernsehgucker sich aussuchen kann, wann er was gucken will. Sagen wir, heute ist Montag, heute stellt RTL, darf ich das sagen?
Klar, hast du ja schon.
Er stellt beispielsweise heute die drei Filme rein.
Und die kann man sich halt aussuchen und heute gucken, egal wann, zu welcher Zeit. Und dann klickt man halt drauf, bezahlt beispielsweise mit diesem Klick irgendwie, keine Ahnung, eine kleine Gebühr.
Aber ich will doch nicht RTL noch bezahlen, also die machen doch schon Werbung, obwohl können sie dann ja gar nicht mehr. Das ist aber eigentlich die Frage, wovon will so ein Sender wie RTL existieren?
Das ist ein ganz großes Problem im Moment, auch was die haben, mit der Einführung dieser Videorecorder, wo man einfach schnell mal die Werbung überspringen kann. Also wo es noch viel einfacher ist, also vorher so ein alter Videorecorder, da muss man erst mal wie in Pausenmodus und drüdrüdrüdrüdrü vorstuhlen. Aber jetzt gehst du halt einfach in Minutenschritten einfach klack klack klack und dann ist die Werbung vorbei. Das ist für die natürlich ein Problem und deswegen überlegen die sich jetzt auch welche neuen Chefsmodelle für die in Frage kommen. Das eine ist halt dieses Product Placement, dieses unsägliche oder auch Schleichwerbung im Extremfall. Oder ja, möglicherweise direkt finanzierte Sachen. Das ist ja auch ein Weg, den RTL jetzt angekündigt hat, indem sie verschlüsseln werden einfach ihr Programm. Das heißt also die Fernsehzuschauer müssen dann speziell noch eine extra Gebühr für RTL bezahlen.
Aber dann guckt das doch. Also realistischerweise, also wer ein bisschen Verstand hat, guckt doch dann kein Privatfernsehen mehr. Die Filme sind sowieso total zusammengeschnitten und gekürzt. Dann kommt noch Werbung zwischendurch. Und dafür soll ich auch noch bezahlen.
Die Werbung fällt ja weg, die guckt ja eh niemand. Die können sich ja dann sparen.
Ja, aber das werden sie nicht tun, oder? Für meine Eltern, meine Eltern werden gar keine Wahl haben. Die werden sagen, ja gut, wenn wir jetzt ATL gucken wollen, dann müssen wir eben diese 2, 50 Euro zusätzlich zahlen. Und dann kommt trotzdem Werbung. Die haben nur ein Fernseher zu Hause. Und dann müssen die trotzdem die Werbung ertrangen, obwohl sie vorher dafür bezahlt haben. Und dann werden sie irgendwann sagen, ne, dann zahlen wir jetzt nicht mehr. Also das ist auch kein Modell.
Na, ich hab mir das eher so gedacht wie so eine Videothek. Also wie so eine Videothek im Prinzip halt bloß zu Hause. Also dass man das runterlebt. Man kriegt es an, kann es gucken und lebt gleichzeitig runter. Also dass man halt nicht mehr diesen Weg zur Videothek hat.
Aber auch da ist natürlich wieder das Problem, wenn es einmal runtergeladen ist, braucht danach nie wieder irgendjemand dafür zu bezahlen.
Es gibt auch so Sachen, dass man es bloß einmal angucken kann oder so was.
DAM heißt das.
Ja, aber das ist, Entschuldige, das ist doch zu umgehen. Und wenn ich es nur analog mitschneide und danach wieder auf irgendeine silberne Scheibe schiebe und dann bei der nächsten Party dir rübergebe und so, hier ist der neue Tatort.
Du wirst es nicht mehr analog mitschneiden können. Klar, wenn das Ganze am PC passiert, dann ist es ein relativ offenes System. Aber ich glaube schon, dass die Zukunft dahin gehen wird, dass die Leute irgendwelche Setterboxen, also irgendwelche Receiver zu Hause haben werden, wo hinten irgendwie der DSL-Anschluss reingesteckt wird und vielleicht der Kabelfernsehanschluss. Und dann geht über eine gestützte Leitung, über HDCP, also dieser digitaler Monitoranschluss, der aber verschlüsselt das direkt in deinen Flachbildschirm rein. Das heißt also, es geht irgendwie hinten übers Netz rein, über eine verschlüsselte Verbindung. Und der nächste Moment, wo du irgendwie drauf Zugriff hast, ist es am Bildschirm zu sehen. Also du müsstest es dann tatsächlich abfilmen wie im Kino.
Meinen VHS-Recorder kriege ich da gar nicht mehr dazwischen?
Vielleicht eine ganz schlechte Auflösung und mit irgendeinem Schriftzug. Das ist irgendwie eine Privatgruppie oder so.
Ach echt, ist das möglich?
Ja, die können über dieses DRM, also Digital Rights Management, wenn die gesamte Kette vollständig digital und verschlüsselt ist, kann man sagen, dieser Film darf jetzt innerhalb der nächsten 24 Stunden angesehen werden. Er darf auf einem verschlüsselten, hochauflösenden Ausgang rausgegeben werden. Er darf auch über einen analogen, aber dann halt nur in ganz schlechter Qualität, nur in VHS-Qualität zum Beispiel.
Wie realistisch ist es denn, dass das nicht auch geknackt wird?
Das ist immer eine Frage des Aufwandes. Und die Frage ist, wenn der gleiche Content natürlich kostenlos in Entauschbörsen ist, dann gibt es überhaupt keinen Bedarf dafür. Das ist auch meine Vermutung, meine These, dass es bei Premiere jetzt relativ lange gedauert hat, bis das ganze System jetzt wieder mehr oder weniger ausgehebelt wurde, ist, dass es einfach das Interesse nachlässt. Also der Content ist einfach nicht mehr interessant. Den ganzen Sachen gibt es im Internet. Warum soll ich mich ja noch irgendwie drei Wochen heransetzen und so eine blöde Premiere-Karte knacken, wenn es überhaupt kein Interesse mehr gibt.
Christian, was würdest du denn zahlen? Also was guckst du beispielsweise für Serien gerne?
Serien gucke ich jetzt nicht so gerne. Ich gucke mir ganz gerne mal so Dokumentationen an. Ich bin jetzt nicht so der typische Fernsehgucker, der sich da Simpsons gucke ich ganz gerne.
Was wäre dir eine Folge Simpsons wert? Weil du im Zweifelsfall müsstest du für jede Folge, die du von irgendwas guckst, irgendwas bezahlen.
Ich sag mal, dass ich mir die DVD von Simpsons auch in einer Videothek ausleihen kann. Also nicht viel mehr als es in der Videothek kosten würde.
Was kostet eine DVD in der Videothek?
Also bei uns kostet es jetzt 1, 50 Euro.
Sind wir großzügig sagen, wenn 1, 50 Euro darauf sind, wie viele Folgen?
6? Ja, das kann man schon sagen.
Durch 1, 50 Euro, das heißt kaum mehr als 20-30 Cent pro Folge. Nicht für die DVD, aber die Frage ist, ob die Senders für dieses kleine Geld anbieten würden dann hinterher. Weil die wollen natürlich am besten 1, 50 Euro haben.
Ja, weil die technische Infrastruktur so teuer ist. Das ist das Hauptproblem, das ist auch das Problem bei iTunes und Co. Also bei den kommerziellen Musikdownload-Stores. Die Technologieanbieter, die verdienen da fast schon am meisten dran. Einfach nur, indem sie diese Kopierschutztechnologie bereitstellen und bei den Schöpfern, bei den Urhebern und Verwertern. Also bei den Urhebern kommt am wenigsten an, bei den Verwertern bleibt dann der ganze Rest. Aber wenn du auf diese Kopierschutztechnologien verzichten würdest, hättest du halt viel mehr Geld für die eigentlichen Schöpfer von Kultur.
Und gucken wir nach Chemnitz, hallo Daniel. Daniel, ruf bitte nochmal an. Entweder war das die Telefonanlage oder ich hab dich gerade rausgeschrieben. Wahrscheinlich war ichs. Nix für ungut, einbeiniger. Falls wir Daniels Nummer haben, rufen wir ihn doch bitte zurück. Falls nicht, Daniel, tu's nochmal. Jetzt drücke ich hoffentlich auf den richtigen Knopf. Hallo, Markus Cottbus. Wie sieht dein Fernsehen der Zukunft aus? Oder wie sieht's jetzt aus?
Jetzt sieht's so aus, ich mach meinen Rechner an und dann guck ich meine Filmchen, die haben wir.
Und wo holst du die her?
Na, ich hab ne TV-Karte drunter, an der ein Sattel-Receiver hängt.
Das heißt, du nimmst sie also über ein Sattelit auf und gehen sie quasi digital über einen Kabel in den Rechner rein. Genau. Und dann guckst du sie am Rechner. Hat das was damit zu tun, dass du dich nicht gerne vor dem Fernseher sitzt? Oder guckst du das nebenbei oder?
Das Problem ist, ich hau für einen großen Fernseher im Moment überhaupt keinen Platz.
Das heißt also, du setzt dich dann lieber an den Schreibtisch, an den kleinen Monitor und äh...
Ich bin ein 17-Zoll-Monitor, also das geht schon.
Okay, klar, ist wahrscheinlich das Gleiche, wenn du direkt davor sitzt, als wenn du so vor so einem normalen Fernseher. Aber mal angenommen, hättest du denn den Platz für den Fernseher, du würdest den auch nutzen wie bisher oder hat sich dein Fernsehkonsum geändert in der letzten Zeit?
Ich gucke im Endeffekt nur noch das, was ich weiß, dass ich gucken will. Ich hab hier eine Standard-Serie und dann schalte ich kurz vorher ein und kurz dann wieder raus.
Wie programmierst du das?
Ich weiß es, ich hab's im Kopf, wenn jemand hier laufen will.
Also händisch, also jetzt nicht irgendwie, dass du so eine Liste hast, wo du einfach nur noch anklickst, haben. Nee, nee.
Ich weiß, wenn sie laufen, dann ist es gut.
Okay.
Würdest du zahlen?
Das ist, ich sag mal so. Im Moment haben wir ja, gut, es geht leider nicht, wenn die öffentlich recht liegen. Na klar, aber schon mal im Moment, ein Geh-Trick, 21 Euro, noch was. Ja, ich sag mal so, ich würde es für jede von euch extra zahlen. Würde ich nicht machen.
Das ist dann auch noch die nächste Frage. Muss ich trotzdem Rundfunkgebühren zahlen, obwohl ich für jedes einzelne Ding zahle?
Das wäre dann doppelt. Und das würde das ja auch nicht bringen.
Die Rundfunkgebühr ist ja unabhängig davon, von dem, was sie privaten senden.
Das zahlt sie über erhöhte Produktpreise.
Das zahlt sie ja letztendlich nächsten Tag im Supermarkt beim Einkauf. Also das Fernsehen ist ja nicht kostenlos. Free TV ist ja auch immer ziemlich irreführend. Der Begriff ist überhaupt gar nicht free. Fernsehen kostet einfach richtig, richtig viel Asche. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht 100 Mal mehr als Radio oder so was oder in der größten Ordnung, aber es ist einfach wahnsinnig viel mehr.
Ich würde sagen, ungefähr 20 Mal mehr.
Das kommt auf den Anspruch an, ja genau.
Ich meine so, wenn man sich die Verteilung anguckt. Ich weiß jetzt, was ist von den 21 Euro Fernsehen? In Deutschland gehen 5 Euro irgendwas an den Rundfunk, aber wir haben auch sehr viele Sender in Deutschland. Das heißt, letztendlich bezahlst du ja hier auch den bayerischen Rundfunk mit. Aber wenn du nach Großbritannien guckst, du hast 10 Pfund im Monat. Davon gehen 50 Penns an den Hörfunk, das heißt ein Zwanzigstel. Also das ist ungefähr 20 Mal billiger, würde ich jetzt mal behaupten.
Was bei dem heutigen Fernsehen eigentlich tierisch auf den Haufen geht, ist die Werbung. Aber richtig tierisch.
Naja, die kannst du ja umgehen, indem du tatsächlich direkt bezahlst. Das ist dann das Modell PayTV, sprich Premiere oder so. Also mal angenommen, es würde RTL ohne Werbung zum Bezahlen geben. Wäre das denn ein Modell für dich?
Wenn die Sendungen so bleiben, wie sie jetzt sind, dann wäre es auch ein Modell, ja.
Also vielleicht ist es, ja, wir gucken uns jetzt hier komisch an, aber vielleicht ist es genau das, was RTL auch mit irgendwelchen Marktforschungen rausgefunden hat, dass die Leute genervt sind von der Werbung und einfach bereit sind, dafür Geld zu bezahlen.
Ja, aber es ist doch komisch, wenn ich in einer 3-5-Stunden-Sendezeit zweimal in einer 5-Stunden-Werbung mache.
Na ja, naja, gut, aber so viel kostet das Fernsehen einfach. So, das ist ja, du kannst ja ausrechnen, was sie... Genau, was eine Minute Werbeminute kostet, du kannst ja ausrechnen, davon muss halt so eine Sendung produziert werden.
Keine Ahnung, also das ist wirklich... Ich hab früher auch nur in der Produktion gearbeitet und ich weiß nicht, was Produktionsminuten damals gekostet haben. Und das hat wirklich wahnsinnig geschwankt, also zwischen 1000 Mark und mehreren. Da bist du dann gerade bei so einer Daily Soap, bei einer ganz billigen. Ich glaub, die hast du auch nicht für 1000 Mark gekriegt, die hat durch 1500, 1600 die Minute gekostet. Die billigen Daily Soaps. Und Tatorte damals, da bist du dann glaube ich schon wirklich auf die 15, 16, 17, 18.000 Mark die Minute gekommen. Produktion. Also bis das Ding wirklich als fertiges Band beim Sender lag. Und dann musst du natürlich auch nochmal die gesamte Sendetechnik haben, die Kosten für Telekom oder wer auch immer dafür das Signal verantwortlich ist. Keine Ahnung, was das insgesamt kostet. Also es dürfte mindestens ein mittlerer, wenn nicht sogar ein hoher, zweistelliger 1000 Euro Bereich sein, was eine Minute Fernsehen kostet.
Ja, und das muss halt durch die Werbung wieder reinkommen. Deswegen gibt es da so viel davon.
Nee, machen sie nicht. Sie machen das... Es kommt einem möglicherweise so vor, vielleicht platzieren sie sie strategisch, also ein bisschen strategischer, also einfach nicht mehr so auf diese Inseln so.
Also es gibt ja nicht mehr...
Und dieses Sponsoring.
Dieser wird präsentiert von...
Genau, was ja auch Werbung ist, aber anders heißt. Das ist natürlich... Ich warte auch nur noch darauf, dass dann im Radio das auch passiert, dass dann auch der Verkehr versponsert wird oder so.
Wo denn? Da musste man 94.5 Radio Cottbus hören.
Das ist ja auch kein öffentlich-rechtlicher Sender. Nee, nee, da geht's jetzt um öffentlich-rechtliche, so was wir auch sind. Also wir haben ja auch unsere ganz klar definierten Werbeinseln, die wir auch mit einem Jingle einläuten sozusagen.
Die haben also kurz vor Nachrichten solche Dinge.
Kurz vor Nachrichten kommt unsere Eigenwerbung, die heißt auch nicht Werbung im internen Sprachgebrauch, sondern die heißt Promo oder Trailer. Da legen die Kollegen, die dafür verantwortlich sind, auch unheimlich Wert darauf, dass es keine Werbung ist. Aber es wird doch was beworben. Ja, aber nein.
Ja, aber es gibt eigene Bänder, die sind da völlig verantwortlich.
Immer nach den Nachrichten und ich glaube um 10 nach auch nochmal. Also je nachdem, was für eine Tageszeit ist.
Also ich sag mal, Radiowerbung ist das, was mich relativ wenig stört. Es gibt aber wirklich einige, die größtenteils, es gibt einige Werbespots, die mir völlig auf den Sack gehen. Ob er meiner Regierung Gottes Wort?
Zumindest nicht um den Sender zu hören, den du gerade genannt hast.
Wir haben so einen hessischen Billigmark bei uns um die Ecke. Und der Werbeswort von denen ist richtig...
Jetzt bist du in der falschen Sendung gelandet, mein lieber Marc. Es ist das Chaosradio und es geht um Fernsehen 2.0, also das Fernsehen der Zukunft. Wo du anrufen möchtest, in welcher Sendung du anrufen möchtest, das ist im Juni, ich kann dir nicht das genaue Datum sagen, es ist einer der letzten drei Mondtage im Juni. Da werd ich nämlich wieder zusammen mit dem Kollegen Niggemeier vom Bildblog eine Fremdmedienbeobachtungssendung machen. Da kannst du anrufen und ordentlich abkürzen.
Ich hab noch mal eine Frage an euch. Wie wird sich denn eigentlich, gibt es da schon Trends, wie sich eigentlich in den nächsten 10, 20 Jahren eigentlich die ganze Werttechnik verändern wird? Gibt es auch dann diese Verschlüsselungssysteme?
Ich glaube schon, dass sich der Markt ganz stark verändern wird. Zumindest im privaten Bereich. Beim Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, das ist so ein Dinosaurier, da fehlt mir so ein bisschen die Fantasie, wie sich da was verändern soll. Die sind ja auch in einer ein bisschen schwierigen Situation, dass sie auch ständig unter diesem Druck stehen, diese Gebührengeschichte, GEZ, was keiner so richtig will. Und irgendwie alle meckern so ein bisschen, ist so viel. Und was passiert denn eigentlich mit dem Geld? Und bei den Privaten, klar, wir haben ja schon gesagt, RTL hat angekündigt, wir machen zack, Verschlüsselung, Monatsgebühr. Nee, ich glaube nicht, da haben sie sich noch nicht getraut. Also es ist auch unterschiedlich. Es richtet sich ja nach, ob es jetzt über Satellit kommt oder über Kabel und so was. Möglicherweise bieten die Kabelnetzbetreiber das noch irgendwelchen Digitalpaketen mit an. Das heißt, man zahlt dann irgendwie 14, 99 im Monat dafür. Da ist dann aber auch RTL mit drinne und 30 pro 7 und so was, sodass man als Endbenutzer eigentlich nichts davon mitbekommt. So würde ich es zumindest als Sender machen, das möglichst schön verpacken. Astra hat angekündigt, auch so eine Technikgebühr zu erheben. Da geht es also darum, ein bisschen von diesen auch sehr hohen Kosten für die Verteilung, also für das Senden über Satellit, auch ein bisschen auf den Kunden umzulegen.
Wer zahlt das bisher? Die Sender selbst?
Das zahlen die Sender selbst. Also in Deutschland haben wir ein ganz lustiges Modell, das ist aber auch kabelspezifisch wieder. Nämlich die Frage, wer bezahlt eigentlich wen mit diesen Kabelnetzen? Wenn ich jetzt ein Kabelnetzbetreiber bin, habe ich ein Interesse daran, möglichst viele Sender bei mir zu haben, um einen möglichst attraktiven Kabelanschluss zu haben.
Damit die Kunden den kaufen wollen.
Genau, weil sonst holen sich die VBT oder eine Satellitenschüsse. Und als Sender, zumindest als werbefinanzierter Sender, habe ich ein Interesse daran, möglichst viele Zuschauer zu haben. Das sind jetzt zwei Sachen, die im Prinzip, das kann man spieltheoretisch betrachten, wer pokert, wer zahlt denn zum Schluss an wen Geld. Und das war so in den Hochzeiten des, in den klassischen Zeiten des Fernsehens ganz interessant. Da wurde dann viel gemauschelt und Geld hin und her geschoben, sodass sich letztendlich fast alles wieder bei plus minus null eingepegelt hat. Mittlerweile kristallisiert sich das so raus, dass die Kabelnetzbetreiber an die Privatsender eine kleine Gebühr bezahlen und dass Sender, die ein besonderes Interesse haben, gesendet zu werden, die aber eigentlich nicht so wirklich attraktiv sind, also ohne die man auch leben könnte, wie zum Beispiel diese ganzen Shoppingkanäle. Dafür bekommt der Kabelnetzbetreiber von den Sendern auch wieder Geld.
Wie ist es beim Öffentlich-Rechtlichen? Also weil die müssen doch glaube ich sogar empfangbar sein.
Ja, dann gibt es noch so Geschichten.
Obwohl das sind sie über alle über DVB-T dann auch.
Dann gibt es über die Landesmedienanstalten eine Mass-Carry-Regelung. Das heißt also Sachen, die dann quasi von den Landesmedienanstalten festgelegt sind, welche gesendet werden müssen und sowas. Aber klar, letztendlich ist es so, dass zumindest beim Satelliten, da ist Astra ein privater Betreiber und der hält für alle die Hand auf. Das ist ganz egal, wobei da kann ich auch einfach als Frank-Rosen-Gartinien sagen, ich möchte jetzt hier gerne irgendwie drei Megabit Bandbreite haben im Monat und möchte keine Ahnung meine was auch immer verbreiten. Chaos Fernsehen oder sowas. Und dann sagen, ja hier bitte, da können Sie Ihr Kabel anschließen und dann kann ich da senden. Also gegen den monatlichen Betrag.
Marc, alle Unklarheiten beseitigt.
Ja, das war der erste Teil. Der zweite Teil ist eigentlich, wie soll denn das? Habt ihr irgendwie eine Ahnung, wie das mit dem TVBT weiterlaufen soll?
Da können wir nur spekulieren eigentlich. Also ich persönlich finde TVBT toll. Ich finde es eine gute Sache.
In Berlin ist es da. Wir sind kurzbezüglich ziemlich am Arsch geschnitten, weil es ist bei uns nicht empfangbar.
Du bekommst aber noch die ersten drei Programme über normale analoge Antenne dann bei euch, oder? Wie es meckern alle über die Bildqualität?
Naja, die Bildqualität ist schon ein bisschen schlechter, weil die Frequenz...
Bildqualität, das ist Fernsehen.
Das ist doch keine HDTV.
Nein, also im Vergleich zur Satellitenübertragung oder Kabel. Also das gleiche Programm ist bei DVB-T einfach bei einigen Sendern durch die niedrigen Bandbreiten, weil einfach das Frequenzspektrum, was zur Verfügung steht für DVB-T, ist die Bildqualität tatsächlich einen kleinen Tick schlechter.
Ja, es sieht eben aus wie VHS, aber da kann ich echt mit leben. Na, ich. Ich kann mit vielem leben. Marc, am besten fragst du mal bei der MABB, also bei der Medienanstalt Berlin Brandenburg nach, wann das soweit ist, dass die jetzt bei euch im Cottbus... Brandenburg, oder...
Am Zug, die Hinterseite von dir.
Jetzt noch MABB.de. Danke für deinen Anruf, Marc. Gute Nacht, tschüss. Chaosradio 113, die Zukunft des Fernsehens TV 2.0. Im Studio der Frank, der Markus und die Knöpfe drückt Herr Holger. Die Zukunft des Fernsehens in Zeiten der Love Parade, die von der Billigmuckibude gesponsert wird.
Und nicht mehr im Fernsehen übertragen wird, zumindest nicht im RBB. Das ist toll dieses Jahr, Love Parade, ohne Wagen, ohne bunte Wagen, ohne Alkohol, ohne Fernsehübertragung, ohne Doktor Motte, ohne Besucher.
Lauter gestellte Körper. Ihr hört das Chaosradio. Ich hab doch nur gestellte Körper gesagt, damit er nicht so mit Trinken schweigen darf. 113 ist unsere Ordnungszahl und das Fernsehen der Zukunft unser Thema. Sie haben euch gefragt, wie ihr glaubt, dass eure Fernseh Zukunft aussieht oder die Zukunft des Fernsehens.
Ob sie überhaupt eine Zukunft hat?
Ob sie überhaupt eine Zukunft hat, ist auch eine gute Frage, sicher. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Nummer für Antworten. Darüber hinaus, vielleicht haben wir auch den einen oder die andere Hörerin im Ausland. Ruf doch auch mal durch irgendwie und erzählt mal, wie es bei euch so ist. Gibt es bei euch einen gebührenfinanzierten Rundfunk?
Wie ist es in Italien?
Oder ist es ein Staatsrundfunk oder gibt es sowas überhaupt nicht? Also es ist komplett privat. Und wie fühlt sich das Fernsehprogramm da an? Und wo geht es möglicherweise hin? 0331 70 97 110. Hallo Mike.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend und ein Hallo in die Chaos-Runde.
Wie sieht dein Fernsehen aus? Hast du 16 zu 9?
Ja, hab ich. Aber? Hab ich, hab ich. Wie sieht mein Fernsehen aus? Also im Moment sehr wenig, weil wenig Zeit dafür. für mich hat auf jeden Fall Fernsehen in nächster Zukunft oder in weiterer Zukunft, auf jeden Fall eine Zukunft, weil ich denke, ohne geht's nicht.
Warum nicht?
Weil Menschen informiert werden wollen. Und alleine nur über das Medium Radio wird es wohl nicht funktionieren.
Aber warum denn nicht?
Warum nicht? Ja, keine Ahnung. Also ich bin eigentlich mehr der Radiohörer, gerade was euren sind, da betrifft. Kleine Schlechtserbung. Nein, aber wie gesagt, weil ich sitze eigentlich mehr im Auto und höre dadurch natürlich gezwungenermaßen Radio. Zuhause habe ich dann nicht mehr wirklich die Zeit, um Fernsehen zu schauen. Aber wenn, dann gucke ich mir doch nur informative Sendungen an.
Und das hilft tatsächlich was bei dir. Also ich habe immer als Beispiel die Kollegen von Radio 1, die haben vor der letzten Bundestagswahlen eine Stunde lang Guido Westerwelle interviewt. Mal davon abgesehen, dass ich den Typen irgendwie total langweilig und Spaßbremse finde und so, war das die erste Chance, die Guido Westerwelle von mir bekommen hat, mir Inhalte zu vermitteln. Also es war wirklich so, dass ich dazu gehört habe und dachte, okay, jetzt weiß ich, was der Mann will. Wenn ich im Fernsehen Guido Westerweller reden höre, dann rege ich mich wahnsinnig über diese selbstgefällige Fresse von ihm auf und schalte weg. Also, von daher, ich weiß nicht, also Fernsehen als Informationsmedium, taugt das wirklich?
Naja, ich sag mal, manchmal, der Mensch ist ja sensationellustig und da kann man ja nun machen, was man will. Zu dem, was er hört oder was er berichtet bekommt, will er dann natürlich auch Bilder sehen. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel an das Erdbeben mir zu denke oder an, ich geh davon, also, nehmen wir mal den Anschlag 2001 auf die Twin Towers in den USA, das Ganze ohne Bilder, schwer vorstellbar, weil die Leute wollen es ja sehen. Die sind ja sensationslüstig und die wollen es ja sehen. Ohne Medium Fernsehen wird es wahrscheinlich nicht gehen.
Ohne Medium Fernsehen hätte es wahrscheinlich diese Anschläge gar nicht gegeben. Gewagte Theorie, aber...
Ja.
Klar, wenn es Medienwirken haben.
Klar, ja, verstehe ich.
Greenpeace müsste sich was einfallen lassen, die können dann nicht mehr auf den Schornstein klettern.
Sie müssten sich zum ersten Mal was einfallen lassen.
Aus dem Blick her habe ich es noch gar nicht gesehen. Ja, stimmt. Es transportiert ja nicht nur Informationen, die der Mensch als solches ja haben will, sondern es transportiert ja auch Geschehnisse, die natürlich dann auch, ich sag mal, negative Gruppierungen dieser Welt sich zu eigen machen.
Ich sag mal, es transportiert nicht die Information, es ist die Information.
Das mein ich, wir können ja mal ganz tief in der medienkritischen Kiste der 70er graben. Natürlich ist Fernsehen auch ein manipulatives Medium. Also das Problem ist einfach, die Macht der Bilder ist überhaupt nicht zu unterschätzen. Und gerade wenn wir so an die Sachen, Berichte aus dem Krieg fernweg von hier denken, da ist es ja ganz, ganz deutlich, wie einfach die Bilder als Beleg genommen werden, für eine Sache, wie sie tatsächlich passiert ist. Und der Einzelne hat ja auch nicht mehr die Möglichkeit, das nachzuprüfen. Also das Problem ist, wenn man die Tagesschau, die ist einfach das, das ist die Wahrheit. Und je authentischer diese Bilder sind, das Fernsehen hat immer noch von allen Medien die höchste Glaubwürdigkeitsquote.
Tatsächlich? Obwohl es doch eigentlich am Unglaubwürdigsten nur sein kann.
Ja eben, es ist komisch dabei, aber gerade wer irgendwie mal in seinem Leben ein bisschen was auch mit Video gemacht hat, es ist halt einfach so einfach, Sachen zu schneiden, so zu schneiden.
Nicht mehr das, selbst wenn du redliche Absichten hast, also wenn ich filme, dann gucke ich in eine Richtung. Ich hab dann einen Ausschnitt von wie viel Grad? 50, 60, 70 Grad oder so und alles was drum rum passiert, kriege ich nicht mit. Und mittlerweile hast du ja auch noch das Problem, da stehen dann zwar diese sogenannten Korrespondenten, aber die machen ja nur noch das, was die Süddeutsche Zeitung mal als gefühlten Journalismus bezeichnet hat. Nämlich erzählen, was man sieht. Anstatt zu erzählen, was man nicht sieht. Das was du siehst, siehst du ja schon.
Klar, also die Idee, dass Journalisten wirklich objektiv sind, das ist natürlich eine Diskussion.
Vor allen Dingen nicht in zweieinhalb Minuten. Das ist ja das Problem dann auch. Eigentlich müsstest du durchsenden.
Radio als solche wurde ja im Prinzip auch schon missbraucht dazu. Weil ich sag mal, in den 30er Jahren gab es noch nicht... Fernsehen war zwar in der Entwicklungsphase, glaube ich, wenn ich mich jetzt richtig erinnere, aber war ja noch nicht das Massenmedium. Da war das halt das Radio, da halt in das Kino mit der Wochenschau. Aber da waren es dann auch wieder die Bilder.
Und da ist auch tatsächlich die Verbreitung des Radios missbraucht worden. Also gar nicht das schon verbreitete Radio. Also das Medium gab es ja noch gar nicht. Das ist ja mit dem Missbrauch erst verbreitet worden in den 30ern letztlich.
Aber worauf ich hinaus wollte, ist ja eigentlich, dass das ja Fernsehen als solches in der Zukunft wahrscheinlich eher so aussehen wird. Dieser Meinung bin ich ja, dass eben das jeder guckt, was er will. Und da denke ich, sind wir wieder bei dem Thema GIZ, das wir da eigentlich von weg müssen. Na ja, weil es sollen sich halt Sendungen oder Sender darauf finanzieren, dass was sie an den Medienabnehmern letztendlich dann auch verkaufen können.
Und dann hast du amerikanische Verhältnisse?
Ja, ich sag mal so, ich weiß nicht, ich guck mir, ich werd dir keine Werbung machen, aber... Ich sag, oder auf MTV Reportagen, auch auf den dritten Programm Reportagen, die natürlich dann aus den GEZ-Gebühren finanziert werden. Aber ich weiß nicht, das kann man doch so gestalten, dass das, was man guckt, bezahlt man auch.
Dann wird nur noch produziert, was die Leute auch gucken und bezahlen wollen. Und genau da sehe ich eine ganz große Gefahr. Darum bin ich zum Beispiel der Meinung, dass wir dringend gebührenfinanzierten Rundfunk brauchen, der sowohl unabhängig von Marktfinanzierung ist, als auch unabhängig von einem unmittelbaren und fast ausschließlich Einfluss durch die jeweilige Regierung oder den jeweiligen politischen Zeitgeist, sage ich mal. Es gibt ja immer wieder Leute, die behaupten, sie würden den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk nicht nutzen. Die behaupten das ganz gerne dann auch mal im Blumen auf Fritz am Telefon. Die nutzen ihn zwar nicht unmittelbar, aber sie profitieren mittelbar davon. Weil letztendlich gibt es dann immer doch noch ein paar Redakteure, die keine Angst davor haben müssen, gefeuert zu werden und die vielleicht den Mächtigen auf die Finger gucken. Nicht mehr viele.
Ja, okay, aber du hast es gerade eben angesprochen. Ich kann mir gut vor... Weil, weil, weil... Ich wurde ja schon darauf hingewiesen, im Einfluss, wie sprägt das, weil wir das jetzt eigentlich mit der GLZ nicht so doll ausbreiten wollten. Aber dann müssen wir doch dahin kommen, dass Leute, die das wirklich nicht empfangen wollen und nicht können, weil sie technisch die Voraussetzungen dafür geschaffen haben, dann auch die Gebühren nicht bezahlen müssen.
Ja, aber das ist ja utopisch. Das ist ja utopisch. Das ist überhaupt nicht überprüfbar. Das ist gar nicht überprüfbar.
Aber das ist ja so, wenn du ein Fernsehgerät zum Empfang bereithältst, dann musst du halt auch zahlen. Wenn du es nicht tust, sprich, kein Fernseher hast, dann zahlst du ja auch nicht.
Aber dass man den Fernseher so umbaut, dass man öffentlich rechtlich nicht empfangen kann, sonst musst du ja bezahlen.
Wie willst du es überprüfen? Dass du es eben doch nicht empfangen kannst? Das kannst du natürlich machen, dann sagst du, okay, dann krieg ich die GEZ jetzt anstatt der 1000 Mitarbeiter, die sie hat, nochmal 5000 dazu. Und die laufen dann rum und gucken die Fernseher an.
Ja, nee, das würde ja auch so nicht funktionieren. Das seh ich ja auch ein. Aber irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wie man da einen Weg finden kann oder wie das funktionieren kann.
Aber wer ist, wenn alle zahlen? Unabhängig davon, ob sie einen Fernseher haben oder nicht. Weil es profitieren ja auch alle davon, unabhängig davon, ob sie einen Fernseher haben oder nicht. Also wenn der Kollege vom Norddeutschen Rundfunk Helmut Kohl auf den Keks geht und fragst, wozu haben sie eigentlich die zwei Millionen gekriegt damals? Von wem haben sie die zwei Millionen gekriegt? Und warum hat Leo Kirch Ihnen einen Beratervertrag gegeben über zighunderttausend Mark, obwohl sie in einem Interview gesagt haben, dass sie keine Ahnung von Fernsehen haben? Wenn der Kollege vom Norddeutschen Rundfunk das macht, Helmut Kohl auf dem Kekse und Helmut Kohl darüber ausrastet und das am anderen Tag in der Bildzeitung steht, vielleicht nicht gerade da, weil das ein Hausmedium war, dann profitiert ja letztendlich auch derjenige davon, der mit der Fernsehgeschichte, die da passiert ist, überhaupt nichts zu tun hatte. Also die Frage ist, wer geht Helmut Kohl dann noch auf den Keks? Vermutlich irgendwann niemand mehr.
Also nicht nur Helmut Kohl. Was mir ganz schwer bewusst geworden ist, war der Irakkrieg. Also beim Irakkrieg der Vergleich der Berichterstattung in öffentlich-rechtlichen Sendern und bei ProSieben, Sat.1, Kirchgruppe damals.
Wie war das?
Also ich hatte subjektiv das Gefühl, dass bei ARD schon noch Wert auf eine objektive Berichterstattung und nicht zu sehr reinfallen auf eine Propaganda, die gesteuert wurde, gesendet wurde. Und das möchte ich eigentlich haben. Also ich möchte dieses subjektive Sicherheitsgefühl haben, dass da noch mehr Objektivität dahinter steht und dass da noch Leute sitzen, die ein bisschen intelligenter Nachrichten machen und nicht nur irgendwie große Show und jetzt Embedded Journalist live aus dem Panzer. Und was man damals bei den Privaten überall sah und was in den USA nicht noch viel schlimmer war.
Ich hab zum Beispiel aufgehört, Nachrichten im Privatfernsehen auch nur im Ansatz ernst zu nehmen, als Peter Klöppel RTL ist. Das sich mal von einem Korrespondenten in einem Krisengebiet mit den Worten verabschiedet hat. Halt die Ohren steif. Da hab ich gedacht, okay, das ist unseriös. Das kann nur unseriös sein.
Also ich mein, mir macht es besonders viel Spaß, erst mal Tagesschau zu gucken und dann irgendwie ProSieben News. Und mal zu vergleichen, wie eigentlich so selbst ARD und ZDF dieselben Nachrichten, dieselben News, wie die anders verpackt werden, wie die Bilder anders verwendet werden, wie die Ansprachen und so weiter und dann am besten auch gleichzeitig rüber zu RTL 2 nochmal schauen, wie man komplett unpolitisch so voll Trash irgendwie dieselbe Nachrichtensendung produzieren kann.
Wenn doch selbst die Öffentlich-Rechlichen schon identische Bilder voneinander verschieden verpacken und als unterschiedliche Nachrichten verkaufen, ist es da mit der Seriosität doch aber auch nicht allzu weit her mehr, oder?
Also ich bin großer Fan der ARD, ZDF kann ich auch verzichten.
Auf Klaus Kleber kann ich nicht verzichten, das ist aber auch der Einzige.
Also bei den Privaten sind die Nachrichten eine Katastrophe.
Warum? Also warum für dich?
Warum für mich? Weil, wie du schon sagtest, völlig unseriös. Vor allen Dingen wird angefangen, im Prinzip ist es, als wenn du die Bildzeitung aufschlägst. Mit dem Unwichtigsten wird angefangen.
Du guckst zu viel RTL 2.
Nee, nee, nee, ich brauch bloß ProSieben anmachen. Um acht die Nachrichten oder kurz vor acht wann die da anfangen. Es ist eine absolute Katastrophe. Und die wichtigen Dinge wie innenpolitische Sachen, nur die Arbeitsmarkt und so weiter und so fort, die werden in diesen Kurzzusammenschnitten da, kurz mal angeschnitten, präsentiert oder wird mal kurz drüber geredet. Und das Ganze ist in einer Minute vergessen. Und dieser unwichtige Scheiß, da wird sich dann, weiß ich nicht, fünf bis zehn Minuten darüber ausgelassen. Und das ist absolut Katastrophe. Also wenn ich Nachrichten gucke, bewusst gucken will und bewusst gucken kann, weil ich die Zeit dafür habe, dann ist es entweder die Tagesschau oder das Heute-Journal. Also das ist für mich seriöse Nachrichtenberichterstattung über Dinge, die sowohl innenpolitisch als auch außenpolitisch passieren. Und das kann man sich auch antun.
Würdest du das weiter in Echtzeit haben wollen oder auch lieber zum runterladen oder zum Abrufen, wann immer du es für richtig hältst?
Eigentlich, ich sag mal, die Nachrichtenredaktionen, die sind ja nun eigentlich immer up to date. Ich gehe davon aus, bei der Tagesschau, ob das bei der ARD oder beim ZDF ist, da sitzen nur 24 Stunden rund um die Uhr irgendwelche Leute, um sämtliche Informationen von der Welt zu sammeln und die dann auch irgendwie so zu verpacken, dass wir die dann in die Nachrichtensendungen reinkriegen. Ich denke, dass sowas dann auch direkt, wenn die das verarbeitet haben, dann ins Netz gestellt werden sollte und jederzeit abrufbar sein müsste. Da komme ich dann zum nächsten Problem, das wir ja in Deutschland haben, ist ja, dass unsere Telekom Dienstleister hier, egal wie sie nur heißen, alle nicht auf die Reihe kriegen, vernünftig schnelle Internetleitungen zu präsentieren.
Zumindest nicht überall.
Zumindest nicht überall. Ich weiß, dass die Telekom jetzt zum WM-Beginn diese 50-Mbit-Leitungen hier mal starten wollten. Ich weiß nicht, wie weit sie da sind, ob sie das überhaupt schaffen. Ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn nicht. Ich habe mal im Spiegel einen Bericht gelesen, wie es da im Südostasien-Raum aussieht. Da sind wir ja schon bei 100-Mbit-Leitungen und so weiter. Also Deutschland als...
Ja, aber die essen auch Hunde.
Ganz kurz, wenn du... Angenommen, wir denken jetzt ein paar Jahre weiter. Das Modell Fernsehen ist so gar nicht, das guckt keiner mehr. Eigentlich gucken die Leute nur noch über das Internet. Ruhig mal 10 Jahre, vielleicht auch 15 Jahre weiter. Das heißt, die Öffentlich-Rechlichen produzieren quasi On-Demand-Sendungen, On-Demand-Content. Wie ist denn das dann mit der Gebühr? Also dann die Rundfunkgeräte zum Empfang bereit halten. Das ist ja eine schwachsinnige Formulierung. Wie würdest du denn die Gebührenpflicht festmachen?
Ja, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, wie man das gestalten kann. Dass man dann, wenn man sich die Nachrichten runterlädt, dass man dann dafür was bezahlt oder wie auch immer.
Aber das ist ja weder das Modell privat Fernsehen oder einfach dieses...
Ich hab da ja eine Idee, aber ich sag die noch nicht.
Ja oder, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht kann man da auch irgendwie... Im Moment bezahlt man ja zweimal. Wenn man jetzt so wie ich in einem hohen Schönhaus, im Plattenbau wohnt, bezahlt du ja die GEZ und dann bezahlst du deine KW-Gebühr.
Und mit deinem guten Ruf.
So, weil ich Schiffe an der Wand hängen darf ich offiziell nicht.
Ach echt nicht?
Nee. Einige Tuner helfen sich da, an denen sie das Ding auf den Balkon stellen.
Also ist der Balkon voll.
Also hat man da wenig Möglichkeiten. Und dann noch mal extra bezahlen, weil du ja dann aus dem KTV irgendwas gucken willst, was dich interessiert. Und ich weiß nicht, wer da noch mal alles abzocken will letztendlich.
Da wäre es dir lieber, dass du einmal 30 Euro statt einmal 15, 10 und 5 Euro bezahlst?
Oder?
Also wenn du nur 15 Euro bezahlst, kannst du halt auch nur 15 Euro Fernsehen haben. Und dann musst du dich halt entscheiden, was es gibt.
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht über den... Habt ihr vorhin schon angesprochen über die Kabelanbieter, dass die dann bestimmte Pakete zurecht stellen. Und da im Prinzip in diesem Paket die GEZ-Gebühr und so weiter schon mit drin ist und je nachdem wie man wie der Kabelanbieter das abgesetzt kriegt, danach richten sich ja dann letztendlich auch die Preise. Also wo dann im Prinzip dieses All in One. Ich nehme jetzt diese Pakete, da habe ich folgende Dokumentationssender, da habe ich Spielfilmsender, da habe ich dann die Nachrichtensender mit drin, was ich gucken will.
Und ein Fünfer für die ARD ist immer mit dabei.
Also das wäre so das. Das Fernsehen in der Zukunft stelle ich mir irgendwann so vor, also mir vorhin auch mit dem Beeman und sowas, was quasi in deinem Haus oder Wohnung oder wie auch immer irgendwann in jedem Zimmer so ein Ding hängt. So und jeder guckt seine Sache, die er gerne haben will. So wenn du Kinder hast, dann buchst du eben noch das Kinderprogramm dazu. So und dann lassen sie sich da vielleicht nicht die 24 Stunden am Tag Zickfilmen bedulden, aber du kommst dann, gehst von Raum zu Raum, guckst entweder überall das Gleiche oder je nachdem, was du gerade haben möchtest.
Das klingt aber so, als wenn dieses mobiles Fernsehen, also sprich Handy TV, wie es immer heißt, auch schreckliches Wort, aber das könntest du dir auch vorstellen. Das heißt, du sitzt irgendwie morgens in der U-Bahn oder nachmittags auf dem Weg nach Hause und guckst denn da dein individuelles Fernsehprogramm?
Ich weiß nicht, ich bin nicht so der öffentliche Verkehrsmittelnutzer, aber ja, weiß ich nicht. Ich meine, mag bestimmt, wie du vorhin schon ausgeführt hast, in Korea oder so, wo die Jugendlichen dann alle mit ihren T-Station Portable da sind oder mit ihren Handys da irgendwelche Tricks filmen oder Nachrichten oder was auch immer. Mag bestimmt lustig aussehen in der U-Bahn oder in der S-Bahn, aber...
Wenigstens pöbeln sie nicht rum. Mike, wir danken an dieser Stelle mal für deinen Anruf. Und gute Nacht. Was ich ja auch noch, also zwei Punkte sind mir eben aufgefallen, und zwar zum einen, angenommen alle Privatsender verschlüsseln und wollen Geld haben. Wie sieht es dann mit so Sendern wie RTL 2 aus? Also das guckt ja niemand.
Nicht?
Es gucken sehr, sehr viele Leute, aber es ist eben tatsächlich, RTL 2 News, die heißen ja noch nicht immer Nachrichten, die werden glaube ich gerade in der Jugendlichen Ziele, also von 14 bis 19 oder so, das sind die beliebtesten Pseudonachrichten. Nur ist das nun genau eine Bevölkerungsschicht und eine Bevölkerungsgruppe, die nicht mal eben noch Geld übrig hat, um das zu bezahlen. Also um die würde ich mir tatsächlich ein bisschen Sorgen machen.
Ich glaube auch, dass es bei den Privaten auch so eine Schere geben wird zwischen den reinen Dudelsendern, die dann auch rein werbefinanziert bleiben, die aber wirklich mit minimalsten Produktionskosten auskommen müssen. Und ein bisschen die hochqualitativen. Ja, also eher so Richtung RTL 2 mit ganz vielen Soapen, Billigproduktionen, Wiederholungen, Schichten. Und es wird halt ein bisschen hochqualitativeren Privatsender geben, die eher in Richtung PayTV, sprich Premiere oder sowas, gehen. Und es wird wahrscheinlich RTL Pro 7 sein, die einfach auch wirklich anspruchsvolles, also ein anspruchsvolles Kinoprogramm liefern am Abend.
Ich mein, das sieht man ja auch schon an den Sendergruppen. Wir haben auf der einen Seite halt die alte Kirchgruppe, die jetzt sabbern oder, keine Ahnung, eben sie jetzt aktuell gehört. Da haben sie Pro 7 und Sat 1 so, mehr für den Premium Content und sie haben Kabel 1 für Dritt, Fürth, Rest, Schrottverwertung.
Dabei komm ich das viel lieber.
Gleichzeitig haben wir die RTL-Gruppe, die halt natürlich auch irgendwie RTL Premium Content plus RTL 2 und gehört Vox eigentlich denen immer noch? Ja, weiß ich nicht, entweder war es mal oder ist jetzt so. Auf jeden Fall, das sind dann die Dritt, Fürth, Fünft Verwertungen, wo man halt den ganzen Schrott nochmal wiederbringen kann, den man halt dann schon mal früher als Premium Content gebracht hatte.
In Großbritannien werden sie mittlerweile nur noch auf Händen getragen. In Berlin treten sie aber noch auf ihren eigenen Beinen auf. Fritz präsentiert die Arctic Monkeys. Life in Berlin. 21 Uhr in der Columbia Halle werden. Die Arctic Monkeys live.
Fritz Info Nachrichten mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
Der Iran hat das Angebot der USA zu direkten Gesprächen über sein Atomprogramm zurückgewiesen. Die amtliche Nachrichtenagentur IRNA sprach am Abend von einem Propagandaschritt. Sofort hatte die US-Regierung ihre bisherige Haltung aufgegeben und sich grundsätzlich zu direkten Verhandlungen mit dem Iran bereit erklärt. Der Auftrag des BND-Untersuchungsausschusses soll erweitert werden. Das Gremium müsse sich auch mit der Bespitzelung von Journalisten befassen, sagte FDP-Chef Westerwelle. Darin seien sich die drei Oppositionsparteien im Bundestag einig. Bislang untersucht der Ausschuss die Arbeit der Geheimdienste im Zusammenhang mit dem Irakkrieg. Der Strafvollzug für Jugendliche muss neu geregelt werden. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht erklärte die aktuelle Praxis für Gesetzes widrig, weil es kein spezielles Gesetz für diesen Bereich gäbe. Bisher können Jugendliche in der Haft ähnlich behandelt werden wie Erwachsene. In Düsseldorf hat die deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft ihr einziges öffentliches WM-Training vor über 42.000 Zuschauern absolviert. Der bisherige Rekord bei einem öffentlichen Training lag bei 20.000 Zuschauern. In dieser Nacht sinken die Temperaturen auf 4 bis 8 Grad, am Tag dann Anfang Sonne, später wieder Wolken, vor allem am Nachmittag örtlich teils kräftige Schauer oder Gewitter. Die Temperaturen erreichen dann 10 bis 14 Grad. Wir haben keine aktuellen Meldungen. RBB-Nachrichten im Netzwerk der ARD rund um die Uhr aktuell informiert.
Also, du wolltest einen privaten verarschen.
Das passte doch.
Ich glaube, für zwei Minuten nach halb zwölf.
Und wenn im Radio 91, 9, dann fritzt rund um Beld sich.
Chaos Radio 113, es geht um die Zukunft des Fernsehens, und zwar technischerseits die Zukunft des Fernsehens und natürlich auch inhaltlicherseits um die Zukunft des Fernsehens und um eure Zukunft mit dem Fernsehen. Der Markus hat eben so schön angemerkt, bisher haben irgendwie Leute immer nur davon ausgegangen, dass sie sich berieseln lassen, so Couchpotatomäßig. Vielleicht hat der ein oder die andere von euch ja auch noch mal eine andere Idee, als sich nur berieseln zu lassen in der Fernsehzukunft 0331 70 97 110.
Chaos Radio Star.
Kannst du mir mal sagen, warum hier steht, dass das noch 50 Sekunden lang läuft, obwohl da überhaupt keine Musik mehr kommt? Oder ist da noch ein hidden track drauf?
Das läuft doch noch.
Dibim, dibim, dibim, dibim, dibim, dibim. Aber wir können trotzdem schon.
Schneidet man immer nur im Radio raus.
Ich könnte noch mal das Dr. Mott Jingle spielen.
Oh bitte nicht.
Chaosradio 113 kümmert sich um die Zukunft des Fernsehens oder das, was ihr dafür haltet, also sowohl für Fernsehen als auch für die Zukunft des Fernsehens. Und du seid natürlich eingeladen, darüber zu sprechen unter 033 177 97 110. Und der Frank aus Güstrow hat angerufen und der hat einen ganz interessanten Beruf zumindest mal gehabt. Hallo Frank.
Hallo.
Was hast du gemacht?
Ich hab heute Klingeltöne verkauft.
Können wir deine Adresse haben? Dann kommen wir mal rum.
Ich stand früher in der Bravo, ist heute aber nicht mehr da.
Ich stand früher in der Bravo, ist heute aber nicht mehr.
Die Firma?
Ach.
Sind die Pleite gegangen oder wieso? Ach so, für dich? Ach so, ich dachte die Firma gäbe es auch nicht mehr.
Doch, doch die Firma gibt es noch, aber halt nicht mehr in der Bravo und auch nicht mehr wirklich im Mobil-Content-Gewerbe, weil das Mobil-Content-Gewerbe seit zwei Jahren eigentlich überschüttet wird von den großen Netzbetreibern der Messe. Und wenn man das jetzt adaptiert auf das Handy und auf das Mobilfernsehen im Handy, bin ich der Meinung, dass es in den nächsten, glaube ich, locker zwei Jahren auch noch nichts wird, weil ich sage, es ist ein Geschäft mit den Eitelkeiten der Leute.
Welcher Leute? Der Mütze?
Der Endnutzer, die es kaufen, die es nutzen. Der Klingelton macht ja nicht wirklich Sinn, weil es klingelt. Weil ich es meinen Freunden zeigen will, wie schön es klingelt und das Logo ist das gleiche in grün. Und im Handy-TV-Bereich nutze ich es nicht, dass ich mir ein Fußballspieler anschaue, auch wenn es technisch gehen würde.
Sondern dazu, dass du es dir anschauen kannst.
Dass ich mir zeigen könnte oder dass ich einen Videoclip zeigen könnte. Und dann fängt das ganze Thema mit Content-Rechten an. Dann fängt es an, was darf gesendet werden? Ich bin ein bisschen in dem Thema Erotik-Content für Mobilfunkgeräte. Da gibt es so viel Rechtstreitigkeiten, dass vor Jahren schon Inhalte produziert wurden, die heute gar nicht für das Mobilfernsehen vermarktet werden dürfen. Wo die Rechtsfrage unten... Ich glaube auch nicht, dass sich jemand Erotik in der nächsten Zeit wirklich in größerem Umfang auf seinem Handy-TV anschaut. Und wie gesagt, die ganzen ProSieben-Site-Einsendungen sowieso nicht. GZSZ, kann man ja sagen, produziert ja und sendet ja auch und wirbt ja auch mit Fri-Folgen, gerade bei RTL. Aber nicht bei der jetzigen Zielgruppe.
Das reicht nicht.
Aber woran liegt das? Sind die Leute das zu klein? Oder ist dieser Anreiz nicht da? Oder ist das zu unbequem? Oder wollen die Leute unterwegs nicht unterhalten werden?
Einmal haben sie diese UMTS-Technik noch absolut nicht. Die Leute, die heute den mobilen Content erwerben, haben mittlerweile Farbdisplays alle. Aber um den Content dorthin zu bekommen, halte ich die technischen Voraussetzungen bei den meisten noch nicht für gegeben. Egal, ob ich jetzt theoretisch für UMTS das empfangen kann, die meisten Geräte, es hat kaum jemand an UMTS gerät.
Aber es könnte ja auch sein, dass zum Beispiel ein DVBH oder DMB-Empfangsteil im Telefon drin ist.
Ja, aber das kann man ja nicht abzählen, wie viele Geräte das sind. Wer soll das steigern, in welchem Moment? Wir schaffen es ja jetzt nicht mal zu steigern. Ich habe sehr lange gewartet, dass ich es gerade noch geschafft habe, mir zur Fußball-WM so ein HDTV-Ressieber zu besorgen. Was ja eigentlich der große Riesenmarkt jetzt sein sollte. So, jetzt gibt es mittlerweile...
HDTV haben sie doch Mitte der 90er schon mal versucht. Da haben sie in Oberhausen damals so ein HDTV-Zentrum gebaut. Da sind Millionen und Abermillionen Steuergelder reingeflossen. Und das war eigentlich nur eine Abzocke, wo einfach Steuergelder mitgenommen werden sollten. Und die sind dann auch mitgenommen worden. Weiß ich nicht, ob das überhaupt noch eine Zukunft hat.
Also HDTV selber bin ich sagenhaft von Begeistert von der Technik. Seit ich das Teil habe, mich sehr im Internet darüber informiert. Was läuft in Amerika? Welche Serien werden wie produziert? Es ist im Vergleich zum normalen Sendeformat ein Traum. Man sieht auch, oder angeblich wollen ja auch Premiere und Co. über das Internet Fernsehen, die es in HDTV, als die Fußball-WM übertragen. Die Qualität ist sensationell, also das macht wirklich Spaß, auf einem Fernseher sich das anzuschauen.
Was guckst du denn da jetzt, weil so viel kommt ja noch nicht in HD?
Deshalb gucke ich da, ich habe alle Kanäle, die es heute gibt, nämlich beide Premiere und den Sportkanal. Und das Ganze ist eigentlich nur in Vorbereitung jetzt auf die Fußball-WM, weil das sehr gut läuft. Und die Filme sind halt selten wirklich schöne. Also ich nutze das jetzt für die Fußball-WM.
Und bist du denn auch bereit, mehr Geld zu bezahlen für HD? Also weil HD kostet ja de facto einfach mehr, also weil die Produktion ist aufwendiger. Du musst, es fängt bei ganz so simplen Sachen an wie bei der Maske, du musst einfach, die Maske muss viel viel aufwendiger sein, weil natürlich die Auflösung ist, du siehst sie in jedem Verhalten. Die ganze Ausstattung, du kannst ja nicht mehr irgendwelche Bretter im Hintergrund zusammen nageln, sondern die müssen ja auch ordentlich verspachtelt sein und so was. Also die gesamte Produktion wird einfach teurer, das Licht muss aufwendiger gesetzt werden.
Also ich hab versucht mich mal damit auseinanderzusetzen, warum die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen das derzeit noch absolut blocken, während ProSieben und Sat1 ja schon Teilausstrahlung machen und auf jeden Fall Kanäle betreiben, wenn auch nicht in der Optimalauflösung, dass es dann am Ende doch ein riesen Kostenapparat ist.
Auf jeden Fall sind wahnsinnige Kosten.
Ich glaube, das ist wie bei allen nachher so ein Erlebnisgefühl. Und ich bin da vielleicht nicht ganz repräsentativ, aber es gibt ja auch einen gewissen Anteil der Leute, die die Premiere kaufen. Und wenn diese Leute nur bereit wären, auf HDTV umzusteigen, dann würde das der ganzen Sache einen riesen Schub geben, denn qualitativ ist das der Hammer.
Das ist der Hammer.
Aber ja, gut, dann kann man Premiere in HD gucken.
Die Frage ist, ob die Leute diese Qualität überhaupt wollen. Also in der Masse, da zweifle ich wirklich noch ein bisschen.
Was will ich sehen? Das ist nachher so, wenn ich mir auf RTL 2 die... Naja, läuft die nicht, die Super Nanny, aber die läuft... Was ich anschaue, dann ist es mir wahrscheinlich sogar egal, ob ich das sehe. Ich muss nicht die hochwertigsten Dokumentationen sehen, aber wenn ich weiß, dass das Material vorliegt, und das ist ja so, ich sage einen Namen nach dem anderen, was man sieht, die 24, die Serie, dass die in RTL TV schon produziert wird von Fox, das würde ich natürlich lieber so sehen, weil es ein gewaltiger Unterschied ist. Ich glaube auch, dass es einfach kommen wird. Es ist vergleichbar mit irgendwelchen Codex, die ich im Internet Video-Stream habe. Ich bin fanatischer Apple-User. Als wir auf diesen 264-Codec rübergesprungen sind, das war schon Welt im iChat. Das macht ja wirklich Spaß plötzlich. Also Qualität wird immer seinen Preis haben, aber Qualität macht halt auch Spaß. Macht Fernsehen Spaß? Weiß ich nicht. Ich habe vorhin, als Sie darüber geredet haben, für wen wird produziert und welche Sendungen sind und Gebühren und soll das gesendet werden? Die Grundfrage ist, für wen wird eigentlich produziert. Ich habe einen nicht mehr ganz so aktuellen Fall, vor zwei Jahren war der. Dort hat die Tagesschau, vielleicht ist der selig bekannt, sehr breit darüber berichtet, über den Fall eines, das hieß damals FDP-Weltfall. Und lief über diese gesamte Donkey-Szene und über Raubkopien und so. Und ich kenne dort diverse Beteiligte an dieser Sache. Und ich fand es interessant, wie die verschiedenen Medien darüber berichtet haben. Und habe mich eigentlich nur hingesetzt und überlegt, wenn das die Wahrheit ist, was sie sagen, wie weit stimmen die anderen Nachrichten, die sie mir dort präsentieren?
Wie war denn die Wahrheit? Oder wie war deine Wahrnehmung der Wahrheit und wie war die Wahrnehmung der Medien?
Es war vorhin schön, die Rede davon, dass man Bilder schneiden kann. Und dass man nur eine kurze Sicht... Man führt Leute in Handschellen ab, man bringt einen kurzen Ausschnitt, man setzt enorme Forderungen der GVU, der Verwertungsgesellschaften in den Raum. Dann habe ich so ein rundes Paket, das über drei Minuten geht. Und am Ende weiß ich aber, das funktioniert alles gar nicht. Das ist auch nicht so in dem Moment, wie es so ist. Mit zig Millionen von Forderungen, wie das hochgerechnet wird und was eine Version kostet und ähnliches. Und dann weiß ich, dort wurde eine Nachricht aus Nachrichten von anderen zusammengebaut. Nämlich aus Meldungen der GVU, aus Meldungen der Staatsanwaltschaft. Jeder hat sein ureigenes Interesse, warum er das so veröffentlicht. Und am Ende kommt dann eine Version raus, die relativ am Ziel vorbeischießt.
Eine latente Kritik, auch in den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen. Ich finde gerade da ist sie sehr berechtigt, weil die natürlich auch noch eine besondere Sorgfaltspflicht haben. Da wird mittlerweile viel zu wenig recherchiert. Da wird viel zu wenig Sachverstand. Man kann sich auch durchaus externen Sachverstand holen. Zu vielen Themen muss man auch. Aber was meistens passiert ist, und das ist jetzt natürlich auch ein überspitzer Vorwurf, aber in der Regel ist es wirklich so, dass irgendwelche PR-Meldungen in eine Nachricht umgewandelt werden.
Die Tendenz wäre einfach auch gar nicht mehr die Zeit da, als zu recherchieren.
Sorry, aber da haben wir eine besondere Sorgfaltspflicht, weil wir kassieren Gebühren, damit wir die vierte Macht im Staat sind.
Das Problem ist aber auch, dass auch bei den öffentlich-rechtlichen Honoraren, gerade an die Freien, natürlich auch im Keller sind und dass da auch gar nicht mehr so viel Zeit bleibt zu recherchieren.
Ja, aber die Festen verdienen gut.
Aber wir sehen aber auch, dass zum Beispiel, wenn wir den Bogen auf die Politmagazine zu spannen, dass die Politmagazine an Zeitkontingenten reduziert werden.
Kein Geld mehr da ist.
Es wird dann Geld gespart und es wird dann hier die Lotushow produziert, wie sie gesagt haben.
Ja gut, aber die gucken auch mehr Leute zu. Aber was man auch den Kollegen vom Fernsehen Politmagazinen vorwerfen kann, ist auch, anstatt sie mal aufzuhören, also sie sollen mal aufhören zu heulen darüber, dass sie eine Viertelstunde weniger senden, die sollen mal ihre Redaktion zusammenlegen und einmal mit einem großen Hammer zuschlagen. Also was brauche ich von jeder Anstalt? Wir haben neun Anstalten in Deutschland, was brauche ich von jeder Anstalt so einen Politmagazin? Dann nehmen wir die Hälfte und die kriegen dann jeweils eine Stunde Sendezeit, wenn jetzt alle...
Aber dann haben wir nicht politisch alle Meinungen vertreten.
Dann haben wir das sowieso nicht.
Ich glaube ja eben, und ich bin mir sogar sehr sicher, dass ich je nach Sendeanstalt von einem oder demselben Thema zwei verschiedene Meinungen einsetze.
Natürlich, natürlich. Aber du hast ja sowieso nie alle Meinungen vertreten. Ich meine, guck mal, wie oft mache ich hier in Blumen zu einem Thema und habe trotzdem nicht alle Meinungen drin, obwohl ich in drei Stunden mit 30 Leuten telefoniert habe.
Ja, ich glaube aber schon, dass die großen öffentlichen rechtlichen, wenn ich die großen beiden nehme, die ARD und die ZDF politisch oft andere Wege gehen. Dass dort viel über diesen Presserat, also nicht über diesen Rundfunkrat, läuft. Das ist was, was wollen die Leute am Ende? Die Tagesschau ist vorhin so gelobt worden. Die läuft 15 Minuten. Dort wird auch runtergerissen. Die Leute wollen... Ich hab mal Anfang der 90er eine Vertriebszeit hinter mir gehabt. Und dort hat man uns diesen Spruch, der ist bekannt, vielleicht immer wieder geprägt, dass man gesagt hat, die Intelligenz ist eine Konstante, nur die Anzahl der Bevölkerung wächst. Was wahrscheinlich auch so ist.
Auch schön. Interessanter Punkt mit der Tagesschau, dass sie 15 Minuten lang ist. Wenn wir nämlich in die Zukunft gucken und sagen, in 10 Jahren vielleicht haben wir Fernsehen und Demand, wir haben vielleicht trotzdem ein gebührenfinanziertes Fernsehen oder einen gebührenfinanzierten Rundfunk, nichtsdestotrotz haben wir das Problem, dass kontinuierlich neue Nachrichten nachkommen. Und die musst du ja irgendwie aufbereiten, also filtern aufbereiten und vermitteln. Und wenn du es on demand machst, hast du natürlich das Problem, dass in dem Moment, wo ich die Nachrichten gucke, lese ich vielleicht im Internet direkt die nächste Meldung, warum habt ihr das nicht in den Nachrichten gehabt, eure Nachrichten sind schlecht.
Ja, aber du kannst gleichzeitig in 10 Jahren dann wahrscheinlich aussuchen, wo die Gewichtung draufliegen soll, ob die Gewichtung jetzt auf politischen Themen liegen soll oder Kultur.
Du kannst es ja jetzt schon auf Tages- schau dir ja auch die Einzelbeiträge gucken. Das mache ich in der Regel, weil irgendwelche Lottozahlen oder Sportmeldungen interessieren mich überhaupt nicht. Ich nehme einfach nur die Beiträge raus.
Wird T-Online zukünftig entscheiden, was gesendet wird? Also wenn es dann Internetfernsehen gibt?
T-Online wird ja erstmal gar keine Öffentlich-Rechlichen haben, so wie es aussieht. Das liegt ja daran, dass die eine Kooperation mit Microsoft haben und das einfach eine grundsätzlich politisch heikle Sache ist, wo auch die Öffentlich-Rechlichen, muss ich einfach mal sagen, auch zurecht sagen, ne, also eigentlich, so ganz ist es nicht so, wie wir uns das gedacht haben. Und da laufen gerade die Verhandlungen. Das hat auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun mit technischen Standards. Die Öffentlich-Rechlichen haben den Wunsch an die Kabelnetzbetreibung gesagt, okay, ihr könnt gern auch über IPTV, also sprich über DSL-Anschlüsse oder sowas unsere Sachen verbreiten. Wir haben Interesse daran, dass wir möglichst breit gesehen werden. Aber wir möchten bitte, dass unser Programm, unser Sendesignal nicht angefasst wird. Das heißt, es geht darum, wenn irgendwelche Zusatzangebote gemacht werden sollen. Das hängt irgendwie an mit irgendwelchen EPG-Daten, also den SI-Informationen, also Informationen SI, was wann läuft, also quasi der Programmführer sozusagen, den ich sehe beim digitalen Fernsehen. Aber auch heik das Thema ist MHP, also für interaktives Fernsehen ein bisschen. MHP gibt es noch, jaja klar. Und das soll also auch möglichst transportiert werden. Und ein Standard, ein technischer Standard, um dieses Fernsehprogramm möglichst unangetastet zu transportieren, nennt sich DVB-IPI. Und das ist ein relativ neuer Standard. Da geht es darum, wie schaltet man, wie wählt man die Programme aus, wie kündigt man an, was läuft, der auch diskriminierungsfrei ist. Das heißt also, das ist also kein von Microsoft dargestellter Programm. Mit den Sachen, was läuft jetzt gerade, wo auf welchem Sender. Sondern es geht darum, wirklich unabhängig diese Informationen weiter zu transportieren. Und das ist eine Sache, die von dem System jetzt derzeit nicht unterstützt wird. Und deswegen sagen die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, ne, finden wir nicht gut.
Ich glaube, dass das Thema sehr gut gewählt ist, auch bei diesem Chaos Radio. Denn ich hab mich in der letzten Zeit mal ein bisschen näher mit dem ganzen Aufnehmen von digitalen Fernsehinhalten über das Internet befasst. Ich hab das nicht von Anfang an zugehört, aber ihr das schon mit aufgenommen habt.
Also meinst du das Online-Videorecorder oder Network-based-PVRs, wie das auch heißen? Nee, hatten wir noch nicht.
Gibt es da eigentlich was, was funktioniert?
Ja, aber es ist nicht legal. Ja, also es gibt diese Online-Videorecorder, es gab jetzt aber auch ein paar Gerichtsentscheidungen dazu, dass die eben nicht legal sind, beziehungsweise, also das ist ganz klar eine unzulässige Kopie, wobei da aber auch, ich glaube, das Gerichte Leipzig war, das hat einen interessanten Leitz, eine interessante Grundsatzentscheidung gefällt. Die hat gesagt, also das ist uns völlig egal, wo das aufgenommen wird, das Entscheidende ist, wo das Sendesignal abgegriffen wird, um es aufzunehmen. Und damit sind dann auch sämtliche Hilfskonstruktionen, die zum Beispiel in Amerika probiert worden sind, dass man sagt, es wird nicht bei meinem Telekom Dienstleister oder irgendeinem Rechenzentrum aufgezeichnet, sondern quasi das Signal kommt bei mir an und ich lager sozusagen nur meine Festplatte aus. Also quasi wie so eine Windows-Freigabe, muss man sich vorstellen, da hat man so einen Server, so ein Dateiserver, ein Fileserver, der dann aber einfach beim Netzbetreiber irgendwo in so einem Rechenzentrum steht. Das hat den Vorteil, dass ich eine relativ billige Setupbox haben kann, so ein Empfangsgerät, so ein Receiver, der aber keine Festplatte mehr drin hat. Und quasi, dass die Daten von mir zwar empfangen werden, aber nicht mehr bei mir im Gerät aufgezeichnet werden, sondern woanders aufgezeichnet werden.
Ich glaube, das wird sich bewegen. Das wird nicht mit einem Gerichtslotter gestoppt sein.
Die Frage ist natürlich, die Sender haben natürlich, die Privatsender haben eben gerade wegen dieser Werbepausen, also die sind ja bei den Werbepausen finanziert, die haben dann natürlich grundsätzlich ein Problem mit diesen ganzen Techniken. Und die werden auch weiter dagegen klagen. Fernsehfähige, genau. Die werden auch weiter mit allen Mitteln gegen vorgehen. Das ist ja ganz klar, weil da wird gerade kräftig gegen deren Geschäftsmodell gepinkelt. Die Öffentlich-Rechts-Liechenden ist das ziemlich wurscht. Die haben nur ein bisschen das Problem, dass möglicherweise die Rechteinhaber, also da wo ARD, ZDF, die Übertragungsrechte, also die Fernsehrechte einkaufen, für Sachen, die sie jetzt nicht selbst produzieren, aber selbst auch da.
Ich meine, wenn man mal überlegt, also der RBB kauft zum Beispiel mir die Beiträge, die ich mache, nicht wirklich ab. Der kann damit noch lange nicht machen, was er will.
Ja, also das ist das Problem, dass die Leute, die die Beiträge machen oder Material produzieren, die müssen ja dann quasi auch in dieser On-Demand-Verwertung zustimmen. Und die Rechte dafür gibt es bisher einfach nicht. Und das gleiche ist bei den Privaten auch. Da sagen natürlich die Rechteinhaber irgendwann auch, ne ne, so geht es nicht, ihr könnt es den Leuten nicht erlauben, ihr müsst da jetzt gegen vorgehen.
Oh, verzeihung, ich hab über den Hustenanfall dein Mikrofon ausgeschaltet.
Man kann das Ganze auch selbst in die Hand nehmen, ohne sich auf Online-Dienste zu verlassen. Es gibt verschiedene Linux-Video-Recorder, die sehr einfach zu installieren sind. Und die sind auch mittlerweile schon sehr komfortabel. Da braucht man dann meistens nur so ein Pentium 2 mit 300 MHz aufwärts.
Diese Linux-Video-Recorder gibt es ja auch für Mac.
Aber du kannst halt einen uralten PC nehmen, der 10 Jahre alt ist. Steckst dann nur eine aktuelle DVB-Karte.
DVB-T oder S oder so.
Kostet so 150, 200 Euro.
Insgesamt aber schon mit einer großen Festplatte.
Genau, da hat man eine große Festplatte drin. Und dann hat man da eigentlich ein sehr komfortables Gerät, wo man dann zum Beispiel auch eingeben kann. Simpsons. Nimm mal alles automatisch auf, wo irgendwie im Programm Tex Simpsons drin steht und schneit auch automatisch die Werbung raus. Und das funktioniert schon. Und wer sich darüber informieren möchte, also es gibt erstmal den Linux Videorekorder. Das ist catsoft.de slash vdr. Kann man sich runterladen, installieren und dann gibt es linvdr vom Heiseverlag noch.
Ist das Kiki Bunty? Also begreift das auch ich mit meiner Susi Standardinstallation?
Du, das ist eine eigene Installation. Das ist eigentlich fast schon Kiki Bunty.
So wie diese Knopfpiks, die du als CD reinwürfst.
Du hast einen alten Rechner, der steht in der Ecke rum, kannst nichts mehr mitmachen, tust da einfach mal eine CD reinlegen und klickst immer auf weiter und dann ist das installiert. Und schließt eigentlich nur das Kabel an.
Das Spannende ist, das Ganze wird dann über einen Webbrowser gemacht. Und wenn du einen DSL-Anschluss hast, eine Flatrate und so einen Router, dann kannst du da über so ein Port Forwarding, kannst du auf deinen Rechner zugreifen und auch von woanders aus übers Internet programmieren. Ich weiß nicht, ob die so was anbieten, den Dienst. Also kann man natürlich auch fertig kaufen, klar.
Das finde ich ja klasse.
Also wir hatten auf dem letzten Linux-Tag Frau Zypress und die Justizministerin da. Und die haben wir dann mal zu denen standgeschickt, wo die ganzen Linux-Video-Recorder von Jugendlichen vorgestellt wurden. Und ich glaube, die hatte auch leicht leuchtende Augen. Also sie hatte keinerlei rechtliche Bedenken dagegen. Sie hatte natürlich die Diskussionen. Uns ging es darum, ihr mal zu zeigen, was so möglich ist, was auch Jugendliche mit alten Computern anstellen können. Und wie man das Ganze mit dem Fernsehen verknüpfen kann. Und sie zu sensibilisieren, dass man das jetzt nicht mal sofort verbieten sollte, wenn am nächsten Tag irgendwie die Filminustrie vor der Tür steht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die hört doch nicht auf euch, die hört auf die Filminustrie.
Uns ging es nur um eine Sensibilisierung da. Rund um die Klarstellung so, hallo, das ist toll, das ist innovativ, das ist nicht illegal und man kann eine Menge Spaß mit haben.
Vielleicht noch einen Blick in die Zukunft zu setzen. Ich glaube dennoch an generell Film über TV, über Internet. Denn ich war in der vergangenen Woche mal wieder im Kino mit meiner Familie. Sackalik.
Scheiß Film, oder? War das nicht ein schlechter?
Ja, das war so schön.
Ein unglaublich schlechter Film. Ich muss das jetzt auch nochmal laut sagen. Das ist wirklich, das ist so rausgeschmissenes Geld.
Wir waren vier Personen und haben 40 Euro bezahlt.
Für den Mist.
Und ich hab mir in dem Zeitpunkt überlegt, ich hab ne Menge DVDs und ich geh nicht mehr ins Kino. Ich warte dann halt und kauf mir für 10 oder 20 Euro, oder wenn ich ein bisschen warte, kauf ich halt für 10 eine DVD.
Stonk gibts für unter 6 Euro mittlerweile.
Und kann mir hier den Abend so gestalten, wie ich will. Und alternativ glaube ich eben, um den Schlusspunkt zu Apple zu finden, da geht demnächst bestimmt auch noch was. Sie haben es gezeigt, dass sie es mit Audioinhalten machen können. Ich glaube, dass der Trend dorthin geht, Filminhalte ebenfalls übers Netz zu verkaufen.
Steve Jobs hat Aktienanteile an Disney.
Ich bin auch ehrlich, für 9 oder 10 Euro würde ich ihn mir in vernünftiger H264 Qualität downloaden. Und ich würde nicht mehr irgendwo hingehen.
Zumal gerade im Kino, was dann noch viel gelobt wird, das Gemeinschaftserlebnis, das habe ich eh nicht, wenn irgendwelche nachschussfressenden Unterschichtler hinter mir sitzen. Jetzt habe ich wieder unbenübt gemacht. Endlich mal wieder das U-Wort gesagt.
Da trinke ich noch einen Schluck Brunnello drauf.
Wie sieht es bei dir mit Handy-Fernsehen, Mobil-Fernsehen? Was für dich? Können Sie das vorstellen, das zu benutzen? Oder ist das komplett ausgeschlossen? An wen ist die Frage gegangen?
An dich.
An mich, Handy-Fernsehen, könnte ich überhaupt nicht mir vorstellen. Ich bin sehr spartanisch wieder geworden, während ich Anfang der, also 99 2000 in dem Hype jegliches Multimeter-Inhaltes war, bin ich jetzt so, dass ich sämtliche PDAs von mir gestreckt habe.
Ach echt, selbst aufs Nokia 770 bist du nicht reingefahren?
Ich brauch einfach noch eins mit zehn Zahlen drauf so. Und grün und rot und annehmen.
Ich find das auch toll. Telefone mit, mit denen man einfach nur telefonieren kann.
Hab ich mir auch geholt. Von Siemens gab's ein hübsches in so Aluminium.
Ich bin sonst von den Ericsson Freak. Aber die sind auch relativ schlicht und klassisch. Und sämtliche Sonderfunktion brauch ich nicht. Ich hab zwei Kinder, die sind 14 oder 15 Jahre alt, also in der absoluten Zielgruppe. Ich weiß, was dort abgeht. Dort ist es seit, wie es vor fünf oder sechs Jahren so war, das Hauptthema ist SMS. Es werden keine MMS-Inhalte verschickt. Es werden keine Bilder verschickt. Es werden auf den Schulhöfen kleine Videofilmchen verdauscht.
Aber warum nicht? Weil kein Bedarf ist oder weil es zu teuer ist?
Ich glaube, den Kosten ist es denen nicht bewusst. Dort auf dem Schulhof wird es verteilt über Bluetooth oder ähnliches. Das andere würde, glaube ich, die Briefsache für aufgehen. Und ansonsten nehmen wir diese TV-Totalfolgen oder ähnliches. Es lädt keiner. Es ist dann doch, dass sie sagen, wir finden das irgendwie so. Wir können das als kleines Quicktime-Movie auf unseren Reichen nochmal anschauen. Aber die Zielgruppe würde das nicht kaufen, weil sie mit dieser Zielgruppe mit diesem Thema, mit dem Produkt nicht wirklich angeben könnten.
Aber wie ist denn das mit deinen Kindern? Kannst du da schon einen Unterschied vielleicht zu deinem Fernsehkonsum wahrnehmen? Also ist es so, dass einfach diese, sag's mal wieder, gelebte Konvergenz mittlerweile da ist? Also quasi Videoinhalte übers Internet gleichwertig mit denen aus dem Fernsehen sind? Wird das irgendwie gedanklich schon verknüpft oder sind das wirklich noch getrennte Medien?
Wenn ich die mediale Nutzung, auch da sind sie glaube ich nicht repräsentativ, sehen kann. Sie haben jetzt hier im Osten Feiertmanns aus der Jugendweide und da habe ich ihnen einen iMac gekauft. Und das ist etwas sehr Schönes, womit sie sehr schön medial umgehen können. Sie können schön ein bisschen was rumbasteln. Sie können sich Filmchen anschauen und herunterladen, was sie auch tun. Sie laden sich diese, dachte ich, Stefan Raab Videos runter und solche Funny Videos. Das tun sie und das macht ihnen Spaß. Sie schauen sich keine DVD darauf an. Sie schauen sich keinen kompletten Film darauf an. Das schauen sie sich eher noch auf einer Playstation an. Ach. Und dann halt auf einem Fernseher. Vielleicht auch, weil die halt einen Fernseher vielleicht noch haben. Damit drinne. Aber das ist dafür wieder eine Qualitätsgeschichte. Sie sagen, ich setze mich nicht von einem kleinen Bildschirm an einen PC oder an einen Rechner und schaue mir auf einem 17-20 Zoll Bildschirm irgendwas an. Nee, da lege ich mich auf irgendeinen Riesenkissen und schaue es mir im Fernsehen an. Sie holen sich die Inhalte auf DVD und im Fernsehen verblöden sich genauso wie alle anderen mit GZSZ und RTL2. Das kann ich auch nicht wirklich steuern. Ich kann sie versuchen zu beeinflussen.
Ich glaube noch nicht mal, dass das Einzige, was du machen kannst, ist ihnen eine möglichst große Medienkompetenz angedeihen. Lassen. Sie in die Lage versetzen zu begreifen, dass RTL2 ein Haufen Scheißdreck ist und dass man das zur Zerstreuung gerne darf, aber sich bloß nicht davon prägen lassen sollte.
Ich habe sie jetzt mit 15 auf meine Lieblings-DVD-Muxmolchen stillgebracht.
So Kinder, das hier ist jetzt die Realität. Ich glaube, verbieten geht da eh nicht. Mit Druck erzeugst du Gegendruck.
Ich glaube, dass das Umgang mit den neuen Medien ein großes Thema ist. Es ist ein finanzielles Thema. Mir geht es nicht schlecht. Ich bin auch an Schulen und sehe dort, da geht es anderen ganz anders. Selbst der normale Umgang mit E-Mail und sonstiges ist für viele auch hier noch nicht so weit fortgeschritten.
Absolut fremd. Das ist auch eine finanzielle Frage. Ich kenne Leute, die haben noch nicht mal einen Computer, weil sie einfach kein Geld dafür haben. Auch nicht die 300 Euro, die man da vielleicht noch verzahlen muss.
Die können sich gar nicht vorstellen, wenn wir davon reden. Ich bringe das beste Beispiel. Ich habe in meinem Haus eine K7-Finanzierung. Von außen habe ich gesagt, ich sitze hier im Glasfasernet. Da bin ich nicht normal in der Hinsicht. Das wird halt irgendwann mal kommen. Ich weiß in meinem eigenen Familienkreis, im Umfeld, da wird das Boden mal angemacht. Die werden sich nie über Internet, Fernsehen in den nächsten zwei Jahren interessieren dafür.
Danke Frank.
Bitte, bitte.
Und gute Nacht.
Auch.
KlausRadio 113, die Zukunft des Fernsehens. Da fällt mir so ein Cartoon ein, das ist so ein Bild, glaube ich. Ich glaube, es ist von Ohl, ich bin nicht sicher. Sascha Hehn darf alles, heißt er. Ich werde jetzt nicht weiter ins Detail gehen, weil dazu muss ich ein Wort sagen, das ich im Radio nicht sagen möchte, jedenfalls nicht allzu oft. Und weil ich ja heute schon mal Scheißdreck gesagt hab, dachte ich mir, das wird... Trotzdem werde ich jetzt nicht, ich werde das V-Wort nicht sagen. Könnt ihr mal die Suchmaschine eures geringsten Misstrauens befragen nach Sascha Hehn darf alles. Die Titelmusik der Schwarzwaldklinik war das eben.
Ach, da war die Fernsehwelt noch in Ordnung.
Ach du, das ist doch 2004, glaube ich. Sind auch alle Folgen noch mal im Nachmittagsprogramm des ZDF wiederholt worden. So 15 noch mal eine selbe Sendung zu jetzt.
So der Folterskandal in Deutschland.
Was?
Der Folterskandal von Deutschland?
Nee, nee, ganz richtig Schwarzwaldklinik. So richtig mit Al-Ghabi-Dom.
Ja, nee, mein ich ja, der Folterskandal in Deutschland. Ist doch ein Massenfolter, oder?
Ich hab den Witz nicht verstanden. Ich dachte, wir würden jetzt gerade in Nostalgie und uns in Nostalgie au chocolat.
Au chocolat. Es gibt ja unheimlich viele, ganze Medienrechnungen, Medienregulierungen, es ist ja wahnsinnig kompliziert. Es gibt irgendwie die ganzen Medienanstalten, Aufsichtsbehörden, Rundfunkgeräte und so was. Und es gibt eine Institution, die finde ich persönlich großartig. Das ist eine ganz wichtige, die machen eine ganz großeartige Arbeit. Das ist nämlich die Kommission zur Ermittlung der Konzentration im Medienbereich. Die KIK, www.kik-online.de. Und die beantworten nämlich alle Fragen, wem gehört eigentlich gerade dieser Sender? Oder wo hat irgendwie Firma oder Herr gerade seine Finger im Spiel? In welchen Sendern? Die beobachten nämlich diese ganzen Besitzverhältnisse, Eigentumsverhältnisse an den Sendern und machen immer schön große PDFs, genau mit welchen Prozentanteilen, wer welche Aktien wo hält und über welche Beteiligungsgesellschaften, wo wieder Einfluss genommen wird. Und das ist ganz interessant und sehr aufschlussreich. Und die sind auch verantwortlich dafür. Die müssen quasi ihr Okay mehr oder weniger geben, wenn es darum geht, wenn Sender fusionieren wollen, verkauft werden, wenn es um diese ganzen medienrechtlichen Erlaubnisse gibt. Kann ich schwer empfehlen, ist sehr aufschlussreich.
Wer sitzt denn alles so drin? Ich gucke gerade, wer so drin sitzt.
Aber das sind in der Regel, also die beobachten einfach diesen Markt und schauen einfach, wo gehen da gerade irgendwelche Anteile hin und her. Und ja, die sind halt auch für diese ganzen medienrechtlichen Zulassungen.
KIK-online.de Genau.
Und da die Übersicht bzw. die Entscheidungen sind auch interessant dabei. Und vor allem bei der Medienkonzentration die Beteiligungsverhältnisse. Da kann man wirklich dann für jeden Fernsehsender schauen, wem gehört.
Rätsel über Fernsehen reden alle mit. Wir haben noch Anrufer, zum Beispiel Henning aus Herne. Hallo Henning. Die ganze Zeit haben wir über Fernsehen von heute gesprochen. Willst du mal über Fernsehen in der Zukunft reden vielleicht?
Ja, ja, kein Problem.
Mach mal.
Ja, also was ich so sagen wollte, ist eigentlich so, die Leute werden eigentlich kaum noch Fernsehen gucken, weil es läuft einfach nur kaum noch was. Und naja, die werden dann selber Fernsehen machen buchstäblich, also selber an Computer irgendwas zusammenschneiden, irgendwelche Filme drehen und dann eben das Internet stellen, beziehungsweise eben zu offenen Kanälen gehen, die ja auch die jetzt finanziert sind.
Also glaubst du das wirklich?
Ja, ich sag's mal so rum. Sehen wir zum Beispiel Linux an, da gibt's eine ganze Reihe an Leuten, die programmieren das und es gibt eine ganze Reihe an Leuten, die konsumieren das nur. Ich denk mal, das wird vergleichbar auch mit Fernsehen aussehen. Vielleicht werden die öffentlich-rechtlich überleben, aber für die privaten sich eigentlich ziemlich schlecht aus.
Also ich mein, Bürgermedien gibt's ja heutzutage auch schon. Also in vielen Städten gibt's einen offenen Kanal. Das war auch so eine Entwicklung aus den 70er und 80er Jahren, sozusagen eine dritte Säule aufzubauen nach dem öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk. Nach dem Privatverband eine zweite Säule, halt ja, offene Kanäle als dritte Säule zu schaffen. Ich sehe ganz klar, dass es zu einer vierten Säule rübergeht, also Videoblocks, das was du auch meintest. Menschen können selbst Content produzieren, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das jeder machen würde. Ich glaube, das wird eine relativ kleine Zielgruppe sein. Diejenigen, die sehr medienkompetent sind, diejenigen, die Lust und Spaß haben, selbst aktiv vorm Rechner zu sitzen. Nicht jeder möchte, wenn er abends nach der Arbeit nach Hause kommt, sich aktiv noch weiter mit sowas beschäftigen. Gleichzeitig ist es ein Problem, oder es ist ein massiver Ressourcenaufwand, selbst hochqualitativen Content zu produzieren. Ich kenne bisher auch nur so ein Label. Oder sagen wir mal, es gibt beim Musikbereich Net Labels, die halt alternative Infrastrukturen schaffen und sich selbst produzieren. Im Filmbereich gibt es in Deutschland ein sehr schönes Beispiel, das ist VEB Film Leipzig unter VEBFilm.de. Die nutzen das Netz, generieren Spenden, stellen alles unter Creative Commons Lizenzen online und nutzen das Ganze, um ihre Projekte zu refinanzieren. Aber selbst die müssen immer auf so 20.000, 30.000 Euro kommen, um sich Ausstattung zu holen.
Aber gerade diese Quotenrenner Boulevard-Magazin, was früher der Treppenhaus-Klatsch war, oder früher der Klatsch unten in der Waschküche. Frau Schneider-Reit, die hat jetzt ihren Mann verloren. Hodenkrebs. Die Boulevard-Befriedigung, die kann man sich ja jetzt schon im Grunde über schriftliche Blogs holen. Da ist es dann auch überhaupt kein Problem, Boulevard per Videoblogging zu machen. Weil da fühl mich dann tatsächlich bloß noch, dass mal wieder irgendwo ein Stau ist oder so.
Das interessiert nur die Leute in deiner Umgebung. Also da kannst du natürlich so einen Lindenstraßen-TV machen. Da kannst du aus dem Fenster heraus die Kamera erhältst und deine Nachbarschaft damit unterhältst.
Aber letztendlich ist es doch wurscht, ob ich jetzt erzählt kriege von Piff, Paff, Zaff, Taff und wie sie heißen, ob ich da erzählt kriege, dass irgendwo in China ein Sack Reis umgefallen ist oder ob ich erzählt kriege, dass Frau Schneiderer als Mann an Hodenkrebs verstorben ist.
Du kannst ja auch eine Lava Lampe auf den Tisch stellen, die flimmert auch.
Ja klar. Ja so ist das doch auch. Oder hier diese komischen Krimiserien. Lenzen und Partner zum Beispiel, wo einfach nur noch mit irgendeiner billigen Handycam drittklassige und fünfklassige Darsteller abgefilmt werden. Das kann man alles selber machen irgendwann.
Na gut, aber selbst so eine Produktion ist teuer. Also in dem Moment, wo einfach Leute ihre Zeit aufwenden. Ich meine, wenn wir nachher alle irgendwie Hartz-IV-Empfänger sind, dann können wir das alle machen, dann haben wir ganz viel Zeit dafür.
Aber kein Geld mehr für die Videokamera und den Breitbandanschluss.
Die werden immer billiger. Also ich meine, wenn du dir heutzutage einen Computer anschaust, so ein herkömmlicher Computer, da ist Ausstattung drin, da ist Software drin, da hättest du vor 10 Jahren, vor 20 Jahren, noch 100.000 Euro für gebraucht, um so ein Studio mit fetter Hardware anzuschaffen. Das ist in der Hand von jungen 10-Jährigen, die kreativ 10 Stunden am Tag Zeit haben nach der Schule und damit rumzuspielen. Da werden wir schon eine ganze Menge an nicht Revolution, aber Veränderungen erleben, aber es wird sehr lange dauern. Wir haben das Problem, dass die über 35-Jährigen, über 40-Jährigen nicht mehr umsteigen zu Produzenten von Medieninhalten in ihrer Freizeit, sondern bis zu ihrem Lebensende weiterhin irgendwie berauscht werden wollen.
Naja, man muss ja auch berücksichtigen, wer soll das dann alles gucken, wenn jeder jetzt ein eigenes Video macht.
Es rauscht, ne? Na, ich mein, also dann rauscht's. Also dann hast du Rauschen. Wenn es zu viele Sender gibt, hast du nur noch Rauschen irgendwann.
Ja, aber es hat auch nicht jeder Zeit, alles anzugucken. Wenn jeder nur 10 Minuten machen würde, dann hätten wir einen Menschen genug Zeit, am einen Tag was man produziert wird, für das Leben zu gucken oder so. Also ich denke mal nicht, dass alle jetzt produzieren werden, nur es werden gewisse Leute anfangen zu produzieren, dann werden sich gute oder schlechte Teile rausbilden und dann werden die guten mehr gegucken, die schlechten weniger. Und das wird dann eben mehr so privat gemacht, zu Hause oder so.
Ja, und gleichzeitig haben wir die Situation, dass man sich viel mehr dafür entscheiden kann, was möchte man gucken und aus einer viel größeren Vielfalt sich sein eigenes Programm zusammenstellen kann.
Ja, aber wie Henning schon sagt, du hast einfach ein zeitliches Problem. Also ich spiele ja in meinen Sendungen ausschließlich Netlabel-Musik und ich verbringe Stunden um Stunden damit, allein den Katalog, den ich zu Hause habe, durchzuhören, immer wieder, wenn die neue Releases haben.
Ja, aber da hast du das Filter. Also du selbst bist schon mal ein Filter für andere Leute.
Ich bin schon mal ein Filter, das ist richtig.
Und selbst du solltest dir dann auch aus Ressourcengründen eigene Filter suchen, die für dich dann schon mal vorhören, denen du vertrauen kannst sozusagen, wo du weißt, die haben einen ähnlichen Musikgeschmack und die bei ihrer Arbeit nebenbei Musik hören und das schon mal vorfiltern und das in ihr Audioblock reinstellen zum Beispiel.
Gute Idee, habe ich noch gar nicht dran gedacht.
Danke. Naja, du musst aufberücksichtigen, man kann ja auch Livestream machen und dann werden vielleicht Leute, die Livestream ins Internet runterladen oder angucken und da wird damit auch schon vorgefiltert. Also es wird nicht immer jeder selber suchen oder es wird Internetseiten geben wie Programmzeitschriften, heute die dann eben so das Wichtigste veröffentlichen so angeblich.
Ja, so Metablogging dann wieder.
Aber siehst du da nicht auch ein gewisses Problem, dass man, also je mehr sich das weiter verteilt, desto schwieriger wird es natürlich auch zu durchschauen, wer steckt da eigentlich hinter und welchen Interessen stecken dahinter. Also bisher haben wir es ja relativ klar, sie wissen halt irgendwie RTL und irgendwie ARD. Und es sind so Sachen, da kann ich mich schon einigermaßen darauf verlassen. Zumindestens wer dahinter steckt oder von welchen Interessen es getrieben wird. So und wenn jetzt die Leute jetzt Content produzieren, dann werden wir schon so Geschichten haben, dass zum Beispiel die Pharmaindustrie plötzlich anfängt, Content zu machen und der dann ungefählt hat, auch an die Leute kommt.
Das passiert beim ZDF heute schon, dass die Arbeitgeber verwendet haben.
Ja, aber das ist schon eher die Ausnahme als die Regel.
Noch, ja.
Und es wird im Internet einfach, denke ich, die Regel werden.
Es ist einfach, die Medienkompetenz wird dann noch wichtiger.
Na ja, die ist jetzt schon sehr wichtig. Wenn ich mir manchmal so die Magazinen auf ID und ZDF angucke, dann weiß ich auch nicht, was da jetzt von der Industrie subventioniert worden ist und was nicht, ne?
Ja, es gibt so die Klassiker der Initiative Neue Soziale Marktwirtschaft. Also das ist dieser, vom Arbeitgeberverband, diese Lobbyorganisation, die es tatsächlich geschafft haben im ZDF in diesem Mittagsprogramm, wo dann immer so 230 Beiträge über irgendwelche anderen Länder oder weiß der Geier was laufen, ganz heftig Beiträge zu platzieren, wo dann irgendwie darüber berichtet wird, wie toll es doch ist, dass in Rumänien ein einheitlicher Steuersatz von 19% für alle gilt. Und die hunderttausenden von Leuten, die verhungern deswegen, die sind da noch nicht mal gezeigt worden. Und da hört es dann auf, ausgewogen zu sein.
Naja, aber ich denke auch, wenn die Leute dann anfangen, alles bei Internet zu saugen, dass die eben auch mal googeln werden, dann werden sie aufwendig auch auf die Seiten kommen, die dann vielleicht kritischer über die jeweiligen anderen senden und so. Da besteht eine Chance, was jetzt zum Beispiel so gar nicht gegeben ist, weil, naja, die ARD und ZDF machen ihr eigenes Programm, aber es gibt eben so keinen Gegensender dazu, der eben das mal kritisiert, dass da vielleicht Fehler drin sind oder so. Genauso ist es auch bei den Privatsinnahmen. Es gibt eigentlich kein Gegengewicht dazu. Und wenn das dann alles so mal ins Internet verschiebt, dann wird es sich auch dieses Gegengewicht bilden, wo dann auch die Leute eben mal gucken können, ach, da ist ja jemand anderes, der hat was ganz anderes dazu gesagt, dass alles eben schief läuft und so. Das wird sich auch mehr herauskristallisieren, aus meiner Sicht.
Auf jeden Fall ist es einfacher, ein Gegengewicht zu bauen. Also das hat Henning schon recht. Wenn ich den Bericht sowieso aus dem Netz kriege, also der kommt sowieso über Google Video oder sonst irgendwas bei mir reingeflogen, dann hab ich das Netz sowieso schon da und offen. Also ist das Internet schon an. Und dann kann ich tatsächlich mal irgendwie ein paar Stichworte in eine Suchmaschine schmeißen.
Ja, und die Leute kommen da auch mehr so auf die Idee, dass es vielleicht alternative Themen gibt. Dann werden wahrscheinlich auch andere Möglichkeiten der Verbreitung, auch populärer werden, vielleicht auch offene Kanäle, dann mehr geguckt oder so. Weil dann auch dann werden auch die versuchen, die Leute vielleicht doch noch in den Fernsehen zu kommen. Dann werden sie versuchen, solche Kanäle eventuell mehr zu produzieren oder so. Das heißt auch, die alten Menschen, die vielleicht nicht so die Ahnung von Computern haben, immer ihre Probleme mit haben, werden vielleicht darüber auch noch was mitbekommen. Also die Chance sehe ich schon irgendwo. Aber das Fernsehen, das wir heute kennen mit ihren Privatsendern, die werden einfach untergehen, aus meiner Sicht.
Weil die Bedudelung, die Berieselung kommt von andersher.
Ja, also ich meine, wer soll sich ständig Deutschland so aus dem Superstar angucken, darf ja auch noch Geld zahlen.
Die Leute gucken es und die werden dafür auch Geld bezahlen.
Die kaufen sich die CD oder den Klingelton?
Ja, nur wenn man sich mal so anguckt und zwangsläufig, wer soll alles noch bezahlen? Die Leute, die es hauptsächlich gucken, sind hauptsächlich Leute, die sowieso kaum Geld haben oder zu viel Zeit haben. Und die Leute werden es einfach zukünftig nicht mehr bezahlen können.
Aber könnte es nicht auch so in die Richtung gehen, dass eine gewisse Elite, nenne ich es mal, eben genau diesen alternativen Content auch aus dem Netz holen, so wie es ja jetzt im Prinzip auch schon ist. Die Leute informieren sich, heute lesen mehrere Zeitungen, gucken mal unterschiedliche Sender. Das ist halt ein kleiner Teil der Bevölkerung. Und der Rest wird halt weiter dieses Doodle-Fernsehen gucken.
Naja, ich denke mal, wenn ich mir so gucke, wie es bei den Jungen so los ist, also mit den jungen ganzen Generationen, naja, die gehen auch schon los. Die informieren sich nicht mehr aus dem Internet oder fangen an, Computer zu zocken und dann auf Fernsehen zu gucken. Also die werden diese Besiedlungen so in dem Sinne von Fernsehen nicht mehr mitmachen. Also wirklich nur die Frage, was macht denn die alte Generation? Aus meiner Sicht, also die Jungen sind da momentan wirklich aus der Reihe Tanten. Die machen wirklich momentan sehr aktiv auch im Internet was. Und es ist wirklich nur die Frage, was passiert mit den alten Menschen. Die werden wahrscheinlich, wenn sie Pech haben, einfach auf der Strecke bleiben. Werden dann noch mit öffentlich-rechtlichen Fenstern...
Ja, oder es gibt dann sowas wie... Also ich hab ja die Vermutung, wenn es mal um Radio geht kurz, sobald es einen Last FM Player für mobile Geräte gibt, kannst du das Musikradio ausschalten. Also dann wird keiner mehr Musik im Radio hören wollen. Das ist dann vorbei.
Das ist ja jetzt auch schon so. Also die Medienanalyse hat ja ganz klar ergeben, dass diese reinen Musikabspielsender auch verlieren.
Ja, aber ich hab ja jetzt wenigstens noch so Sachen, also dass ich sage, wenn ich jetzt auf Dancehall und Reggae stehe, dann höre ich freitags abends von acht bis zehn Fritz. Nichtsdestotrotz muss ich mir da auch Sachen anhören, die mir vielleicht nicht gefallen. Und wenn es nur die Stimme des Moderators ist. Und sobald eben tatsächlich jemand hingeht und einen Last FM Player für irgendein UPNP-Handy herstellt, dann komme ich nach Hause und dann läuft da meine Musik. Da läuft überall meine Musik, wo ich das haben will. Und sowas fürs Fernsehen dürfte so schwer auch nicht herzustellen sein.
Wobei, meine Theorie ist ja, dass die Leute nicht nur ihre Musik hören wollen. Du willst ja auch mal ein bisschen Input haben. Den Anspruch haben viele Leute schon, dass du einfach nicht nur dein Programm zusammenklickst, sondern du willst halt immer noch ein bisschen extra Input haben, was Neues hören. Und das macht ja auch so ein Radioprogramm aus, wenn man sagt, das ist jetzt ein scheiß Lied, aber irgendwie freue ich mich, das ist ein Wahnsinn, genau so.
Darum finde ich Arte so toll, weil ich da 50 Prozent der Sachen, die da kommen, verstehe ich noch nicht mal.
Aber bei, also das Stichwort User Generated Content, dafür wird ja auch gerade viel geredet drüber, aber ist nicht auch der Wunsch da, auch wirklich professionell produzierten Content zu haben? Also wollen wir wirklich nur Unterhaltung oder Information auf, sag ich mal, auf einem Kanalniveau haben?
Naja, ich denke mal, Fernsehsinnung wie 24 Stunden oder sowas, die wird das auch immer noch geben, nur dann eben irgendwie per Video und Demand, also zahlen oder eben per DVD kaufen oder sowas. Also sowas wird es immer noch geben und es wird auch immer noch irgendwelche Leute geben, die meinen, sie wollen jetzt irgendwelche Videos gucken mit ein paar Freunden oder so, das wird das auch in Zukunft geben und da wird auch wahrscheinlich immer noch möglich sein, irgendwie Geldzumme zu verdienen, aber so wie es heute aussieht, wird es einfach nicht mehr geben. Also höchstens vielleicht so eine Art kleinen Fernsehprogramm noch, wo vielleicht die aktuellen Serien kurz vorgestellt werden oder sowas, aber das ändert sich eigentlich auch schon wieder. Ja, also ich denke mal, das Einzige, das überleben werden, sind die öffentlichen Rechnungen, weil die werden einfach über die GEZ finanziert. Die offenen Kanäle werden auch über die GEZ finanziert, sind aber dementsprechend auch kostengünstig für die Leute, die hier auch mitmachen wollen. Da wird immer auch die Ausrüstung kam, um zum Beispiel auch für Hartz IV-Empfänger, dass die ja auch ein Programm machen können und dann bleibt eben nur das Internet. Übrigens, die Privaten werden eine Schichtstunde greifen, zunehmen, abschalten oder sich eben anpassen müssen.
Also ich sehe eine große Gefahr, dass es das öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk irgendwann gar nicht mehr geben wird.
Nein, ich meine, die Privaten nicht geben wird. Die Öffentlichen werden es noch geben.
Ja, und ich sehe das genau andersrum. Wenn du zum Beispiel anschaust, heutzutage werden ARD und ZDF schon künstlich aus dem Internet rausgehalten. Also die dürfen nur 0, 75 Prozent ihres ganzen Etats für Internetsachen ausgeben. Und sie dürfen im Internet auch nur Programmbegleitung machen. Das ist der Grund, weshalb ich irgendwie die ARD-Politikmagazine mir nicht per Podcast runterladen kann. Oder andere Dinge. Das ist eine politische Entscheidung. Das ist vor allen Dingen eine Entscheidung, um die privaten Player zu schützen. Ich bin damit nicht einverstanden.
Absolut nicht.
Ich finde die BBC ist ein sehr tolles Beispiel, die in unserem Nachbarland zeigt, was man machen kann, wenn man als öffentlich-rechtlicher Rundfunk innovativ das Internet einsetzt. Ich träume eigentlich davon, dass die ARD endlich mal irgendwann aufwacht, dass die Politiker in Deutschland irgendwann mal aufwachen.
Was ARD intern bedeutet bei ARD-Mitarbeitern?
Ich weiß. Aber ich träume davon, dass wir in Deutschland mal die Situation haben, dass die Politiker es zulassen, dass ein öffentlich-rechtlicher Sender in Deutschland so wie die BBC rum experimentieren kann. Und ich kann ja vielleicht mal kurz erklären, was die BBC alles so macht. Die BBC steht einerseits vor dem Problem, dass es nicht ganz klar ist, ob sie in zehn Jahren immer noch Steuer finanziert. Gebührenfinanziert.
Das heißt Tax, aber es ist eine Gebühr.
Auf jeden Fall, ob sie immer noch irgendwie öffentlich-rechtlicher Rundfunk sein wird oder Medienunternehmen, das ist vollkommen unklar. Auf jeden Fall fangen sie jetzt schon an, sich zu öffnen unter so einem Motto benutzt unser Zeug, um euer Zeug zu machen. Das ist sehr vielschichtig. Sie entwickeln auf der einen Seite einen eigenen Medienplayer, der leider Digital Rights Management Funktionalitäten enthält, aber das Ganze als freie Software. Der spielt eine sehr zentrale Rolle zukünftig, damit die Leute ihr eigenes BBC Programm zusammenstellen können. Es ist geplant, leider noch nicht so wirklich vollzogen, dass unter einer speziellen Creative Commons Lizenz das ganze Archiv geöffnet wird, zumindest die Sendungen, wo man halt klar die Rechte besitzt. Dazu gibt es halt sehr kleine technische Spielereien. Die ganze BBC-Seite besitzt offene ARPs. Man lädt quasi die Nutzer ein, selbst die BBC Informationen zu remixen, eigene Wetterberichte zu erstellen und experimentiert halt damit herum, dass man Innovationen an den Rändern zulässt. Nämlich bei den Nutzern. Und das ist nur so ein kleiner Teil. Das wird zukünftig noch sein, dass halt die ganzen Nutzer ihre eigenen Radiosendungen produzieren können, da einstellen können, so Citizen-Journalism-Blogbeiträge schreiben können. Und das ist eine Ergänzung von dem, was die Journalisten, die eine sehr hochqualitative Arbeit da ableisten. Also vor BBC habe ich einen heilen Respekt vor der Arbeit.
Selbst vor der Unterhaltung, die die produzieren. Das sucht seinesgleichen.
Genau. Und sie gehen halt den Weg, das Ganze irgendwie ergänzen zu lassen von den Zuhörern und damit rum zu experimentieren. Einfach mal Freiheiten zuzulassen und die Zuhörer, die Zuschauer an den Produktionen zu beteiligen.
Du beobertest das auch relativ intensiv. Warum klappt das in Deutschland nicht? Warum kriegt die ARD das deiner Meinung nach nicht? Von außen.
Das ist A ganz klar diese politische Entscheidung. Die werden aus dem Internet rausgehalten. B die Entscheidung, bis du im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk endlich an entscheidenden Stellen angekommen bist, dann bist du eigentlich schon so alt, dass du dich gar nicht mehr mit technologischen Innovationen beschäftigst. Das ist eine Kompetenzfrage dann auch. Ich glaube nicht, dass die jungen, dynamischen, jungen Journalisten, die im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk sitzen, dass die tatsächlich Freiheiten haben, irgendwie rum zu experimentieren.
Ich dachte, die werden nicht gehört. Wir werden nicht gehört.
Ja, also bis man dann endlich mal, also diejenigen, die Entscheidungen treffen, die werden wahrscheinlich nur die ganze Zeit in ihrem eigenen Sumpf verbringen und noch in diesem alten Denken, wo auch viele deutsche Medienpolitiker drin hängen. Also die denken alle im Landesrundfunk anstalten, die denken alle mit Radio und Fernsehen, die kriegen überhaupt gar nicht mit, dass da gerade so ein interaktives Internet irgendwie draußen alles revolutioniert und dass man nicht mehr dieses klassische Top-Down-Denken oder Broadcast-Denken hat, sondern dass man auf einmal kommunizieren kann, in Dialog treten kann und die Nutzer beteiligen kann.
Jobert, zu Lebzeiten derer, die da entscheiden, wird es das, was sie kennen, nämlich das herkömmliche Broadcasting, garantiert noch geben. Und dann irgendwann ist der Zug abgefahren, das kann passieren. Henning, entschuldige.
Ja, man muss auch vorsichtig sein. Wenn das zunehmend immer so populärer wird, dann bietet auch der politische Druck immer größer, das auch so zu ändern. Weil die Politiker wollen ja auch nicht unbedingt, dass ARD und ZDF dann völlig untergehen.
Die Politiker fürchten wie der Teufel das Weihwasser, dass sich eine echte demokratische Diskussionskultur entwickelt.
Naja, ja, so um den Dreh.
Ich glaube eher, das Problem ist ja klar, wenn du als Politiker bei den öffentlich-rechtlichen Ansätzen kriegst, das natürlich aus vollen Rohren aus der Richtung. Und das traut sich glaube ich keiner.
Nein, nein, ich meine in der Hinsicht, sie wollen erst diesen Monolog aufrechterhalten und werden dann versuchen, das ins Internet zu bringen, nach Hoffnung, dass die Leute das gucken und dann nicht in den Alltag gehen können. Dieser Druck wird entstehen. Auf der anderen Seite wird es immer mehr Leute geben, die das eben sagen, wir haben kein Fernseher mehr oder wir benutzen kein Fernseher mehr und wir wollen das gerne ein paar Intents noch mal nach runterladen oder noch mal angucken oder so. Und da wird auch ein großer Druck entstehen. Die Atomenergie-Gegner haben es ja auch geschafft, mehr oder weniger nach extrem langer Zeit zu schaffen, dass der Atomausstieg rankommt.
Ja, aber jetzt gibt es eine andere Regierung und das wird gerade komplett geändert. Das ist nix irgendwie, ein steingemeißeltes Leiter der Atomausstieg.
Ja, aber selbst die CDU muss irgendwann mal in eine Realität ankommen und die Realität heißt, dass von wieviel? 198 Ländern gerade mal 20 oder so, die Atomenergie haben. Das ist jetzt auch nur noch mal ein Aufbäumen, oder? Es ist eben ein langer Weg, wie Henning sagt. Vielleicht braucht man einfach noch 20 Jahre.
Ja, also ich mein, ich denke auch. Also mal angucken, von Anfang darum Energiegegnerbewegung und dann bis heute, wo wir wirklich so weit sind, das hat auch 20, 30 Jahre gedauert. Und das wird auch mit ARD und ZDF 20, 30 Jahre, wenn nicht, soll aber noch länger dauern.
Also, warten wir mal 50 Jahre.
Es wird vor allen Dingen auch noch funktionieren. Also meine Eltern sind jetzt so zwischen 16 und 70 Jahre alt. Die werden noch 20, 30 Jahre leben wahrscheinlich. Und solange werden die Fernsehen, ja.
Ja, also es ist nur die Frage, was macht die alte Generation? Die junge Generation wird umsteigen, zwangsläufig. Und die alte Generation werden weiter gucken. Das ist ein Prozess, ein Generationenprozess eben.
Wobei irgendwann werden sich die Leute dann vielleicht auch in einer hinreichenden Anzahl weigern, einfach zu bezahlen, oder? Weil, wenn ich aufhöre, wenn ich wirklich aufhöre, Fernsehen, also Broadcasting zu nutzen, dann bin ich auch nicht mehr bereit, für Broadcasting zu zahlen. Ich bin dafür bereit, Rundfunk, ich bin jederzeit bereit, Rundfunkgebühren zu zahlen. Wie gesagt, ich finde das wichtig. Aber ich bin nicht dafür bereit, etwas zu bezahlen, was ich dann hinterher nicht kriege, weil ich kriege es ja aus dem Internet faktisch nicht.
Ja, und da wird es auch zukünftig auch gewisse Änderungen geben. Auch, ich denke mal, die GEC wird so vielleicht irgendwann noch mal revolutioniert. Und dann wird einfach schlicht und knapp alles erhoben. Und man sieht jetzt schon Computersäuren, die nun jetzt auch erhoben werden nur noch. Und da mal zukünftig die Art, die man im Computer braucht.
Aber da hast du ja genau den Punkt. Sie wollen Gebühren, die Rundfunkanstalten wollen Gebühren für das Internet haben. Weigern sich aber oder werden daran gehindert. Wie auch immer ist mir auch ehrlich gesagt scheißegal, woran es genau liegt. Ich soll für mein Internet bezahlen, bekomme aber den Tatort nicht über meine Datenleitung geliefert.
Oder andersrum, jetzt beschweren sich alle um Gottes Willen. Die wollen jetzt irgendwie GEZ-Gebühr für das Internet haben. Aber eigentlich wünschen sich ja alle, dass der Content auch im Internet ist.
Ja, aber dann soll er erstmal da rein, oder?
Ja gut, ist das so ein bisschen ein Hennen-Eye-Problem.
Ja, sicher, sicher. Aber der Tatort ist ja schon da. Dann sollen sie ihn einfach mal draufpacken. Ja, aber ich sehe, dass ich was davon habe. Ich glaube, damit kriegst du die Diskussion doch noch relativ schnell einigermaßen abgewandert.
Da ist noch das kleine Problem mit den Rechten. Über das Internet gibt es ja keine Ländergrenzen mehr. Und da ist das Problem mit den Lizenzen. Die Rechte werden dann unglaublich teuer. Wir haben das ja jetzt schon bei der Satellitenübertragung. Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum zum Beispiel das österreichische Fernsehen die Satellitenübertragung verschlüsselt, einfach um Lizenzgebühren zu sparen. Weil der Satellit ja macht ja nicht an Ländergrenzen halt, sondern der strahlt es ja schon über ganz Europa aus. Dementsprechend sind die Lizenzen teurer.
Können die das nicht über IP-Adressen machen? An der Stelle, wo dann über diese Lizenzgeschichten diskutiert und nachgedacht wird, wenn man den Leuten erzählt, wir können das mit IP-Adressen rausfiltern, die glauben das doch, die Verstehung war nicht mehr, oder?
Ja, aber dann hat es halt so skrile Ausmaße, dass wenn du jetzt einen Film richtig legal kaufen willst, aber irgendwie dummerweise gerade einen amerikanischen Provider hast oder einen Proxy benutzt, der irgendwo in der Schweiz steht, dann sagt er, tut mir leid, sie sind nicht aus Deutschland, sie können sich nicht kaufen.
Wenn das jetzt wirklich so ausmartet, dass dann niemand mehr diesen Content kaufen kann, dann wird ja noch keiner kaufen, sodass sich auch der Preis senken muss. Dann soll ich sowas wieder kaufen können und so. Dann wird es noch einiges geben. Oder es wird eben Notfalls über dir angelöst. Also das ist die einzigste, naja, schlimmer, weil ich es daran sehe, aber ich denke nicht, dass die Tagesschau darunter leiden wird. Weil das ist ja hauptsächlich von ARD oder ZDF selber produziert. Und es sind auch diese kleinen Serien, die selber produzieren. Aber diesen Content, den sie kaufen, das wird wahrscheinlich teurer werden oder eben verschüsselt.
Oder gar nicht mehr bei denen stattfinden. Weil dann kaufe ich eben beim Content-Anbieter direkt. Also warum soll ich jetzt noch die ARD beauftragen? Kauf mal bei MGM irgendeinen Spielfilm. Den kann ich dann letztlich bei MGM auch selbst kaufen.
Oder da werden eben Programme, die die Leute selber gemacht haben, verstärkt gesendet, ne?
Wie auf RTL 2 jetzt, wo sich irgendwelche Idioten dabei filmen lassen, wie sie gegen die Wand laufen. Komisches boing, boing, boing, boing da drüber und alle lachen.
Also ich hab immer noch den stillen Wunsch, dass sie es nie machen werden, aber...
Ich auch.
Irgendwann wird das kommen oder irgendwas anderes, also...
Ach Gott. Hoffentlich wollen die mich dann noch. Henning, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Vor der WM ist nach der WM. Und nach der WM ist vor der WM. Aber mittendrin ist... Fritz präsentiert Pop-Kick 06 im Treptower Park Berlin. Vier Wochen FIFA-Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft auf Großleinbach. Und dazu jeden Tag Konzerte. Los geht's am 9. Mit dem Eröffnungsspiel Deutschland-Kosta Rica. Eigentlich schon komplett ausverkauft. Aber Fritz hat für euch 100 Karten reserviert. Und die geht's natürlich nur zu gewinnen.
Einfach gut Fritz hören.
Pop-Kick 06, das größte Großereignis zum großen Großereignis. Und mittendrin die Radio-Fritzen. Ab 9.6. vier Wochen lang im Treptower Park Berlin.
Und im Radio. Fritz, vom RBB.
Mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
Der Iran hat das Angebot der USA zu direkten Gesprächen über sein Atomprogramm zurückgewiesen. Die amtliche Nachrichtenagentur IRNA sprach am Abend von einem Propagandaschritt. Zuvor hatte die US-Regierung ihre bisherige Haltung aufgegeben und sich grundsätzlich zu direkten Verhandlungen mit dem Iran bereit erklärt. Die Opposition im Bundestag will den Auftrag des BND-Untersuchungsausschusses erweitern. Das Gremium müsse sich auch mit der Bespitzelung von Journalisten befassen, sagte FDP-Chef Westerwelle. Bislang untersucht der Ausschuss die Arbeit der Geheimdienste im Zusammenhang mit dem Irakkrieg. Der Strafvollzug für Jugendliche muss neu geregelt werden. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht erklärte die aktuelle Praxis für Gesetzes widrig, weil es kein spezielles Gesetz für diesen Bereich gäbe. Bisher können Jugendliche in der Haft ähnlich behandelt werden wie Erwachsene. In Düsseldorf hat die deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft ihr einziges öffentliches WM-Training vor über 42.000 Zuschauern absolviert. Der bisherige Rekord bei einem öffentlichen Training lag bei 20.000 Zuschauern. In dieser Nacht sinken die Temperaturen auf 4 bis 8 Grad am Tag. Etwas Sonne, dann wieder sehr viel Wolken und vor allem am Nachmittag örtlich teils kräftige Schauer oder Gewitter. Die Temperaturen erreichen 10 bis 14 Grad. Eine Meldung von der A11 Berliner Ringrichtung Uckermark zwischen Werberlin und Chlorin in... Chlorin, hm, Chorin in beiden Richtungen. Gibt es Behinderungen durch Tiere auf der Fahrbahn. Bitte Vorsicht auf der A11 zwischen Werberlin und Chorin. Ansonsten wünschen wir gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank, Matthias Gerkhoff. Gleich 7 Minuten nach Eberheiz.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6... Dann Fritz in Berlin.
Die Zukunft des Fernsehens. Ich weiß, was sie sagen wollen. Ich weiß, was sie jetzt sagen wollen und sie haben recht. Ich hätte Robin Masters anwesen nie verlassen dürfen. Das war Magnum. Wir sprechen über die Zukunft des Fernsehens im Chaos Radio 23 und eigentlich wollte ich jetzt gerade Daniel rannehmen, aber irgendwie der Knopf geht nicht. Erzähl mal was Frank. Jetzt geht der Knopf. Ja, danke für das Sitzfleisch, warten.
Also meine meine Zukunft Aussicht, die Fernsehen aussieht, sag ich mal, ist denke ich auch, dass es so in Richtung freier Radios geht. Vielleicht vielleicht gibt es ja irgendwann ein Chaos Fernsehen, also Chaos Fernsehen statt Chaos Radio sozusagen.
Du willst uns doch nicht wirklich sehen.
Ich glaube manchmal habt ihr schon gesagt, schön wär's.
Okay, würdest du uns dafür bezahlen? Nein, ganz ganz einfach, wenn 3000 Euro im Monat zusammenkommen, dann machen wir es. Ganz einfach.
Im Moment bezahlt ja auch niemand fürs Chaos Radio.
Doch, Rundfunkgebühren.
Ja gut, okay, das kann man ja genau so...
Achso, warte mal, der Frank möchte jetzt mal hier unbedingt einmal den Knopf rücken.
Komm Frank, drück den Knopf.
Geht's? Schon gezahlt?
Ich finde, das sollten wir jetzt irgendwie immer Dr. Motte, ne? Das lass ich jetzt mal.
Aber um noch mal auf das eigentliche Thema zurückzukommen, wo ich noch ein Problem hab, ich hab schon mehrmals versucht im Prinzip im Internet auch bei hochwertigem Journalismus, in Anführungszeichen halt, ARD, CDF und so weiter, irgendwelche Videos abzurufen, sag ich mal. Also Begleitprogramm.
Woran machst du hochwertigen Journalismus eigentlich fest?
Ja, das sag ich mal, das sind halt Leute, die das studiert haben, oder was weiß ich. Die wirklich dort Erfahrung haben und vielleicht mit ihren Kollegen sich noch austauschen können. Ich sag mal so, es ist sicherlich sinnvoll, wenn es freie Radios zusätzlich gibt. Aber ich persönlich will jetzt trotzdem weiterhin die Informationen abrufen können und wäre auch dafür bereit, so eine Art Flatrate-Gebühr oder was weiß ich, zu bezahlen. Aber das Problem ist halt die technische Seite. Ich hab seit sechs Jahren Linux und ich kann das Zeug, was bei CDF oder so rumliegt, nicht abrufen so direkt. Das ist alles Windows, Media oder Real Audio oder so. Das ist alles proprietär irgendwie.
Mit einem M-Player kann man das schon machen.
Man braucht meistens nur extra Codex.
Das ist alles sehr hässlich und ohne drauf zu klicken und man will draufklicken.
Vielleicht kommt irgendwann mal noch 64-Bit-Codex raus. Ich hab einen 64-Bit-Regener und da geht das mit dem M-Player nur im Change-Route. Also quasi...
Das ist sogar einer von denen, den nicht nur klicken wollen.
Ja, also das ist halt eine klare Sache, die man eigentlich fordern müsste von öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunksendern, dass sie ihn auf einen Standard senden. Bisher macht das nur das Deutschlandradio. Die bieten ihren Stream als OKWORBIS an. Das ist ein offenes Format, theoretisch überall abspielbar. Wahrscheinlich nicht im Windows-Media-Player, aber das wird halt alternativ noch angeboten. Und das sollte halt natürlich auch für sämtliche Streams gelten. Bisher wird halt alles nur im Real-Stream oder im WMV-Stream, Tagesschau und so weiter, gestreamt.
Hast du da mal nachgefragt bei den Sendern, warum sie es nicht machen? Also ich würde es dir zutrauen, dass du da jetzt irgendwie mal anrufst.
Technische Entscheidungen. Also die Entscheider haben da meistens keine Ahnung. Denen wurde dann irgendein Real-Server verkauft und so weiter. Und das konnten auch 90 Prozent der Leute irgendwie sich anhören. Und das ist dann so eine Entscheidung.
Also beim Fußball war das so. Da haben wir tatsächlich auch mal nachgefragt, warum das so ist. Und da ist es eine rechte Frage, weil nur Windows Media, da gab es noch nicht mal Real, dafür nur Windows Media, ist in der Lage, diese geografische Zuordnung zu machen, in diesem Rechne-Management einzubinden. Und da war es einfach ein Lizenzproblem bei den Fußballübertragungsrechten. Generell ist es natürlich so, dass es wirklich eigengerecht zu machen ist schwierig. Und ich glaube, auch wieder BBC da Vorreiter, die auch gesagt haben, okay, wir machen jetzt einen eigenen Videocodec.
Ja, das läuft alles derzeit nur mit Windows. Mit diesem Special Interactive Media Player, der wiederum, ich glaube, sogar den Windows Media Player noch braucht. Also das ist noch total unschön hässlich.
Vom Ansatz natürlich eigentlich ganz gut, aber im Prinzip gibt es ja auch schon freie Alternativen. Wenn man die ein bisschen fördert, dann könnte das was werden.
Das Problem ist halt, die müssen immer irgendwo ihr Zeug finanzieren. Also die müssen ihre Werbung unterbringen oder was will ich, oder ihre Tarifierung irgendwie machen. Und dann muss man den Nutzer irgendwie ein Stück Kontrolle entziehen, sage ich mal. Das geht halt mit der Open Source schlecht, weil da kann der Nutzer irgendwie immer die Programme dann abgreifen.
Na gut, bei den öffentlich-rechtlichen wäre es ja kein Problem in dem Sinne. Also da ist auch Werbung drinne. Es ist natürlich die Frage, wenn die Werbung dann wegfällt, wenn alles on demand kommt. Man kann ja auch die Werbung in das on demand einbauen, so ist es ja nicht. Man kann ja auch einen kurzen Werbespot vorher machen. Dann wird es ja halt mit der Medienregulierung ganz schwierig.
Es ist ja nicht Sinn der Sache, dass es über Werbung finanziert wird. Von daher, finde ich, sollte das in die Leben erst mal gar nicht mit reinfließen.
So was nehmen wir auch in Kauf im Prinzip. Also ich höre auch schon Online-Streams und so weiter mit Werbung eingebettet. Also das würde meiner Meinung nach sogar relativ gut funktionieren.
Ich wäre froh, wenn ich keine hören oder sehen müsste.
Oder du würdest auch dafür bezahlen?
Also sofern ich über die Mittel verfüge. Das ist ja dann auch immer noch die Frage. Also irgendwann ist auch nicht mehr genug Geld da möglich.
Also da sehe ich im Moment übrigens eine ganz interessante Wandlung im Fernsehen, in diesem gesamten Umschwung, weil bisher ist der Rundfunk, also Fernsehen, Radio auch, denke ich schon als Kulturgut betrachtet worden. Im weitesten Sinne. Weil es war einfach da, es konnte jeder sehen. Ich hatte die Möglichkeit, wenn mich Werbung genervt hat, konnte ich halt einfach pinkeln gehen, aber ansonsten konnte ich das Programm von RTL einfach konsumieren. Ich konnte sehen. Und die Leute, die da arbeiten, also der einzelne Redakteur, der unten arbeitet, der hat, behaupte ich mal, unterstelle ich mir einfach mal, auch einen gewissen Anspruch, einfach Fernsehen zu machen. Wir machen hier Fernsehen für die Bevölkerung. Also das ist schon so ein bisschen von einer Idee her, zumindestens auf der unteren Ebene. Es ist einfach nicht da, es geht nicht darum, hier ein Wirtschaftsgut zu schaffen, sondern wir machen hier Rundfunk. Einen gewissen Anspruch auch.
Glaubst du das wirklich?
Ja, schon. Also die Leute, die die einzelnen Beiträge machen, die haben nicht dieses wirtschaftliche Denken im Kopf, sondern die haben irgendwie schon alle noch ein bisschen einen journalistischen Anspruch.
Ja, aber spätestens, wenn der dritte oder fünfte Beitrag, wenn da nicht die Kamera lang genug auf die weinende Mutter geguckt hat oder sowas und es deshalb nicht gekauft wurde, spätestens dann lässt du deinen Anspruch doch auch fahren.
Klar, das ist der Druck auf die Produktionsfirmen, aber den gibt es immer in öffentlich-rechtlichen, leider auch streckenweise.
Ja, sicher, sicher. Das wollte ich jetzt gar nicht sagen, dass wir da besser sind. Da hast du natürlich das Problem, wenn irgendwas nicht läuft, wird es abgesetzt.
Genau.
Und da geht dein Anspruch dann aber auch irgendwann den Bach runter.
Das ist richtig, aber wenn wir jetzt umschwenken auf diese, nennt sich Grundverschlüsselung, so einen blöder Begriff, heißt es eine Verschlüsselung, wo also ganz klar ist, du Fernsehzuschauer, du Kunde, du Geld bezahlen und wir Fernsehsender, wir produzieren und nehmen das Geld ein, dann ist es einfach Fernsehen, ist dann halt ganz klarer Fall, da Verkäufer, da Käufer, das ist irgendwie ein geschlossener Wirtschaftskreislauf. Und da denke ich mal, das ist schon auch eine Art von Paradigmenwechsel. Also natürlich ist es eine idealistische Anschauung von dem, was Fernsehen bisher war, wenn man das als Kulturgut betrachtet, aber mit diesem zunehmenden Maß, Sachen mit Zuverschlüsseln, DRM zu sichern und sowas, es ist einfach ganz, also ich sehe da einen Trend schon in Richtung Wirtschaftsgut einfach Fernsehen. Also es geht einfach darum, wirklich Inhalte zu verkaufen. Und ich denke auch, dass sich das auch noch mehr festsetzen wird, denn auch in den Redaktionen.
Und das Kulturgut, das schaffen dann die Nutzer in ihren eigenen Videoblocks, in ihren eigenen Berichterstattungen?
Ja sicher, ich denke, es wird eine gute Mischung geben aus dem Ganzen. Also eine Art freie Kultur, wie es halt jetzt schon ist. Es wird nur eben einfach multimedial ausgedehnt. Je mehr Bandbreite und so zur Verfügung steht, wird halt aus Audio, wird halt Video. Im Prinzip, also die Blocks sind Text und Audio teilweise noch. Wird halt später Video draus. Beim Fernsehen wird es sicherlich auch weitergeben. Wer eben bereit ist, die für den Content zu zahlen, dann wird auch die verschlüsselten Sender bezahlen. Aber wird eben alles im Prinzip parallel existieren. Und auf jeden Fall wird es natürlich digital sein, weil das analoge Fernsehen, denke ich, stirbt aus. Weil es halt für die Sender auch vielleicht kostengünstiger ist, wenn die das...
Ich glaube, Analogsenden ist auch teurer, oder?
Klar, die Bandbreite ist teurer im Analogen.
Ich habe wirklich die Befürchtung, dass es in einem Maße rauschen wird, dass man es irgendwann einfach gar nicht mehr nutzt.
Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum die Privatsender gar nicht so ein großes Interesse hatten, überhaupt digital im Kabel zu sein. Weil mit der Digitalisierung des Kabels ist die Vielfält auch größer geworden. Das heißt, die Nutzer hatten plötzlich mehr Auswahl. Für Privatsender ist es ja viel interessanter, wenn einfach nur 10 oder 15 oder vielleicht 20 Sender drin sind, wovon die Hälfte irgendwie Shopping-Kanäle sind. Wenn nachher 100, 200, 300 Sender da sind, dann gehen die irgendwann unter. Das heißt, sie müssen viel mehr Aufwand treiben, um ihre Marke zu festigen. Die Marke RTL oder Sat.1 Pro 7 einfach bekannt zu machen und aufrecht zu erhalten. Als wenn es nachher in so einer Masse von 200, 300 Sendern untergeht.
Es geht im Zweifelsfall jetzt schon nach hinten los. Sat.1 Powered by Emotion war ja so ein Ding, was dann irgendwie als der erste gesagt hat, Powered by Emotion, Kraft durch Freude. Da waren die also, das war wirklich die, die waren knapp davor, einen richtig heftigen Imageschaden mit einer Werbekampagne einzufahren. Und das nur, weil sie versucht haben, die Leute stärker zu vereinnahmen, als ihnen das bisher möglich war. Also das war ganz knapp vor dem Gau. Das haben sie auch relativ schnell wieder abgeschafft.
Das ist ja so, der Stärkste bleibt halt am Ende übrig. Also es ist eine ganz normale Konkurrenz in der Marktwirtschaft im Prinzip. Es wird halt irgendwann sicherlich dann auch einzelne Sender, dass die aussortiert werden irgendwie.
Und das letzte Wort, erteilen wir mal Axel. Hallo Axel.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Wie guckst du heute und wie guckst du morgen?
Ja, heute gucke ich glücklicherweise noch analog und bin eigentlich ganz froh darüber. Obwohl ich mittlerweile der Meinung bin, die Kollegen versauen das analoge Bild immer mehr. Es verrauscht immer mehr.
Es verrauscht?
Es verrauscht immer mehr. Also rein von der Bildqualität her verrauscht es immer mehr. Ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie ein genialer Schachzug ist, um mir beizubiegen, dass die neuen digitalen Bildfehler besser sind als die alten analogen.
Auch die Kabel rosten einfach nur.
Also ich habe große Probleme mit digitalen Bildfehlern. Ich mag nun mal keine Mosaikfilter. Und das sieht irgendwie alles gemein aus. Und ich mag auch nicht, wenn ich das fliegende Haar einer Dame plötzlich Klötzchen zu sehen kriege. Und das ist irgendwie eine ganz große Katastrophe.
Womit guckst du da? DVB-T oder was ist das?
Nein, ich habe ein paar DVB-T-Erfahrungen in Berlin zwangsweise machen müssen und habe festgestellt, nie wieder. Katastrophe, bleibt mir fern damit. Kabelanschluss ist noch gut, aber ich habe langsam das Gefühl, dass man da ein bisschen beginnt zu spielen, dass die eingeschleißte Bildqualität schlechter wird. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt eventuell nur ein Anschein von mir ist oder ob gerade mein Kabelbetreiber Probleme hat mit dem Kabel. Es ist aber eine große Katastrophe. Wenn irgendjemand denn endlich mal schaffen würde, das, was die PAL-Qualität liefert, wirklich zu übertragen, kein Mensch braucht der HDTV. HDTV bringt nur den, was sie verkaufen. HDTV ist nichts weiter als eine große Verarsche. Und die HDTV-Bildqualität wird die PAL-Qualität nicht wesentlich überschreiten, weil das übermittelte Signal so weit von Daten kastriert ist, dass man sich das nicht angucken kann. Also ich bin der Meinung, dass es bis vor knapp einem Jahrzehnt war man wirklich noch der Meinung und hat man sich wirklich Mühe gegeben, immer bessere Qualität in Bild und Ton zu liefern. Dieser Trend ist einfach vorbei. Heutzutage wird der Nutzer nur noch mehr und mehr kastriert und es wird ihm immer mehr versucht, im Prinzip immer weniger versucht, als immer mehr zu verkaufen. Und deshalb sehe ich also die Zukunft des Fernsehens relativ finster. Und für mich wird der Monitor im Endeffekt nichts mehr sein, als die Wiedergabemöglichkeit von gespeicherten Daten. Und es wird, solange wie es geht, auch immer noch ein analoge Röhrenmonitor bleiben. Bildfehler aller digitalen Monitore sind eine Katastrophe.
Das geht bis 2010, oder?
Das analoge Fernsehen, naja, in Berlin gibt es keinen.
Ja, aber analoge Röhrenmonitore wird es länger geben.
Klar, aber selbst da ist das Bild ja dann auch schon digital, wenn es digital empfangen wird.
Ja, aber dann hab ich jetzt nicht noch die zusätzlichen digitalen Bildfehler dazu.
Musst du nicht wieder Pixel rauskneten, meinst du?
Ja, so was in der Art. Auf der letzten Funkausstellung war an einem ganz nett versteckten Stand von Audio-Video ein Vergleich völlig wertfrei, ohne dass man die Hersteller der Fernsehgeräte gesehen hat, zwischen den derzeit drei großen Wiedergabesystemen, also ein Röhrensystem, ein LCD und ein Plasma-TV. Im Endeffekt, zusammengefasst gesagt, das beste Bild liefert der Röhrenfernseher. Alles andere ist, naja, reden wir nicht drüber. Ein hin und her schwiegendes Pendel produziert dann irgendwelche Ecken.
Unterwirfst du dich denn eigentlich dem Zeitdiktat des Fernsehens noch, oder bist du davon schon weg?
Ich unterwerfe mich eigentlich kaum dem Zeitdiktat des Fernsehens, da ich kaum noch Fernkauke. Also ich verwende den Fernseher tatsächlich überwiegend dazu, wenn ich denn fernschaue, dass ich die Tagesschau gucke. Ja, es ist irgendwie die letzte Nachrichtensendung, der man noch einigermaßen trauen kann, wenngleich auch deren Wetterbericht mittlerweile zu einer Comic-Show missraten ist, kann man sich nicht antönen. Aber ansonsten ist es noch irgendwie eine Nachrichtensendung, die man sich angucken kann. Für die brauche ich auch keine 3 Meter Bildschirmdiagonale, weil die Tagesschau reicht mir auch auf meinem 20 Zoll. Da sind wir also bei meiner 20 Zoll Fernseher. Sehr viel größer ist das einfach nicht. Über alles andere, wie gesagt. Ja, userproduzierten Content. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich als Alternative irgendwie eine OKB-Qualität ständig nur sehen will. So toll ist das wirklich nicht. Denn das, was man so im OKB in Berlin im Fernsehen sieht, reißt mich also nicht so sonderlich vom Hocker.
Aber manchmal ist auch eine Perle dabei.
Ja, aber die Perlen sind doch sehr dünn gesät. Da muss man irgendwie ein Viertelfund Ausland schlachten, um vielleicht mal eine Perle zu sehen.
Ja, aber da kommt es auch auf die Masse an.
Ja, ich befürchte aber, ja, das ist irgendwie trotz allem eine Gleichverteilung, die hin und wieder mal einen kleinen Ausbrutscher hat. Und der Ausbrutscher ist arg selten gesät.
Also das Internet hat halt ganz andere Möglichkeiten als ein offener Kanal. Wie lange oder was muss man überhaupt machen, um eine Sendung im offenen Kanal platzieren zu können, wenn ich mein eigenes Video-Blog... Ja genau, aber wenn ich mein eigenes Video-Blog habe, dann muss ich sie nur machen und habe sie sofort online gestellt.
Muss man haben, der die Bandbreite bezahlt.
Ja, dann stehe ich bei YouTube.
Ja gut, aber dann wie Holger eigentlich schon immer zu sagen fliegt, das Rauschen dessen ist natürlich gigantisch.
Ja, du brauchst dann... Ja, das sagte Markus dann, du brauchst Filter wieder.
Du brauchst wieder Filter.
Und dann hab ich tatsächlich das Problem, ja, welchem Filter vertraue ich denn? Wann kann ich denn feststellen, dass ich welchem Filter wirklich vertraue?
Im Grunde hast du dann schon wieder... Irgendwann kommst du wahrscheinlich wieder genau da an, wo wir jetzt schon sind. Dass du nämlich sagst, okay, da ist die Tagesschau, da kann ich wenigstens noch einigermaßen vertrauen. Und der Rest ist ja dann auch irgendwie eher...
Ja, reden wir nicht drüber.
Also das ist ja... Ich bin mal gespannt, wie sich das entwickelt.
Irgendwie hab ich tatsächlich auch noch so richtig Probleme mit all den ganzen Datenströmen, die mir aus dem Internet als Livestream zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Die Bildqualität derer ist nicht so, dass ich sage, das möchte ich mir ständig angucken.
Das wird besser.
Ja, sicher wird das besser. Selbstverständlich, aber wenn mir alle Leute sagen, das ist umsonst, ist das auch ein bisschen sehr zäh. Ich meine, ich brauche dann immer noch ein Rechner dazu und ich brauche eine einigermaßen funktionierende Flatrate dazu, die auch ein bisschen Bandbreite bietet. Ja, ganz umsonst ist es da auch nicht. Gut, ich meine, ich kann die Flatrate für andere Sachen verwenden und muss nicht ständig nur fernsehen. Aber auf die Art und Weise würde ich mir glaube ich nicht unbedingt deinen Film angucken wollen.
Danke Axel, wir sind am Ende.
Ja, wir auch.
Wir auch. Danke für deinen Anruf. Tschüss, machs gut. Was haben wir noch vergessen? Ungefähr 80 Prozent dessen, was wir auf dem Zettel haben.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich noch ein bisschen was erzählen, wie Premiere das irgendwie schaffen könnte. Vielleicht auch die Bundesliga tatsächlich auch über Kabel und Fernsehen zu zeigen. Da gibt es einen kleinen technischen Kunstgriff, ob sie damit juristisch durchkommen, werden wir sehen. Vielleicht noch ein kleiner Hinweis, eine eigene Sache. Wer sich ein bisschen mehr für die technischen Details interessiert, wie zum Beispiel Datendienste über Satellitenübertragung über DVB funktionieren, was es da so gibt, wie man Internet per Satellit irgendwie auch empfangen kann, was es da für Geschichten gibt unter Linux, wie man damit spielen kann, Spaß haben kann, Spaß am Gerät. Es gibt bei uns einen sogenannten Datengarten im Chaos Computer Club Berlin. Und der findet nächsten Donnerstag, also nicht morgen, sondern in einer Woche statt. Und da gibt es eine kleine Einführung in das Thema Datendienste per Satellit und einen kleinen Hands-on-Workshop für Linux.
Dann drück nochmal den Knopf, komm, hast du so viel.
Dankeschön. Ansonsten kann ich nochmal Werbung machen für netzpolitik.org. Da gibt es auch ganz viele Informationen über die Zukunft der Medien. Politische, gesellschaftliche, kulturelle Änderungen und Prozesse.
Und ich mach Werbung fürs Chaosradio. Das war Chaosradio 113, Fernsehen TV 2.0. Ich will sie immer noch. Persistenz heißt das.
Sponsor bei O'Reilly.
TV 2.0, die Zukunft des Fernsehens, das war unser Thema. Das nächste Chaosradio hört ihr wie immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Das ist der Monat Juni. Und da ist es dann der 28.6. um 22 Uhr auf allen Frequenzen von Fritz und sonstigen Verteilungswegen, Distributionswegen zu Destinationen überall auf der Welt.
Und wenn ihr noch Fragen habt, Hinweise und Sachen für die Sendung oder auch überhaupt an uns, dann schickt eine Mail an chaosradio.ccc.de Im Übrigen gibt es den Chaos Radio Express.
Das ist ein Podcast, den findet ihr auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de bzw. in iTunes. Es geht weiter mit Martin Petersdorf hier im Soundgarden. Ich bin heute irgendwie ein bisschen total doof. Ein bisschen total doof. Im Night Flight. Vielen Dank Frank, vielen Dank Markus. Mein Name ist Holger Klein. Danke für die Aufmerksamkeit. Gute Nacht.